Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Pridlaff und das hier ist die 115. Ausgabe von UKW.
Und ja, vor allem wenn ihr hier vielleicht aus welchen Gründen auch immer das
erste Mal reingeschmissen werdet, könnte man vielleicht nochmal kurz was dazu sagen.
UKW ist ein Podcast, der sich so ein bisschen entwickelt hat und so in den letzten
Jahren ein wenig zum Krisenbegleit-Podcast geworden ist.
Und ganz viel davon, wie auch heute, begleite ich gemeinsam mit Pawel. Hallo Pawel.
Hallo Tim.
Und anders als wir jetzt die, ja fast schon zwei Jahre wieder, ne?
Irgendwie Ukraine begleitet haben, machen wir heute mal ein neues Themenfeld auf.
Ein Thema, über das ich schon länger nachgedacht habe,
ob man das nicht mal in irgendeiner Form behandeln sollte, aber ehrlich gesagt
immer so ein bisschen vor mir hergeschoben habe,
weil es wahrscheinlich das denkbar schwierigste und komplexeste politische Krisenthema
der Welt überhaupt ist, der Nahostkonflikt.
Aber nun, nach den Terrorangriffen der Hamas in der letzten Woche,
genau vor einer Woche, wir haben heute den 14.
Oktober 2023 und vor einer Woche am Samstag,
am Schabbat, gab es diese Angriffe, die jetzt natürlich die Welt beschäftigen
und die ein ohnehin schon immer loderndes Feuer im Nahen Osten wieder komplett auflammen lassen.
Ja und dann haben wir uns irgendwie so unterhalten und haben überlegt können
wir diesen Kerlchen uns vorbeigehen lassen oder nicht.
Und ich würde meinen es gab verschiedene Faktoren die glaube ich jetzt hier
eine Rolle gespielt haben bei der Entscheidung uns dieses Thema dann doch nochmal aufzunehmen.
Erstens, wir verfolgen ja nun das Ukraine-Thema schon lange und der Konflikt
mit den Russen ist ja nicht nur ein lokales Problem und auch hier spielt die
Weltpolitik eine große Rolle,
nicht nur weil Russland involviert ist, sondern eben auch andere Kräfte wie der Iran.
Und ja, das ist natürlich auch eine Konstellation, die in diesem Nahost-Konflikt
schon immer eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Und natürlich wird auch dieser neu aufgeflammte Konflikt Israel in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten Auswirkungen haben, auch auf die Art und Weise,
wie die Ukraine voranschreiten kann. Also mit anderen Worten, alles hängt zusammen.
Dann ist es natürlich auch so, dass dieser Konflikt, dieser Nahostkonflikt,
ich habe es ja auch schon gesagt, mit zu diesen kompliziertesten ältesten Konflikten der Welt gehört.
Man könnte fast sagen, es ist vielleicht sogar der älteste Weltkonflikt,
den es überhaupt gibt. Mir würde jetzt zumindest nichts einfallen dazu.
Und ich stelle halt auch immer wieder fest, und das stelle ich auch an mir selber natürlich fest,
irgendwie erscheint einem das dann alles als viel zu komplex,
viel zu schwierig, viel zu viele Sichtweisen, dazu noch ein mega aufgeheiztes
politisches Gesamtfeld.
Alle haben da irgendwie Meinungen und keine Meinungen könnten hier irgendwie
extremer auseinander liegen als in diesem Bereich.
Ja, und dazu kommt natürlich noch, dass der Konflikt mit Israel natürlich auch
die deutsche Geschichte nochmal ganz speziell tangiert.
Und die besondere Rolle, die Deutschland dort eingenommen hat durch den Zweiten
Weltkrieg natürlich dann auch nochmal hier im Hintergrund lodert.
Und das alles nicht einfacher macht, das für sich selber aufzudröseln.
Bis hin zu natürlich dem Echo, das dann nicht auf Berliner Straßen oder in vielen
deutschen Ländern dann auch stattfindet,
weil dort natürlich auch Juden und Palästinenser hier in nicht geringer Zahl auch bei uns leben.
Das heißt, das hat auch von daher Auswirkungen direkt auf uns,
obwohl ja glücklicherweise es bisher noch halbwegs ruhig geblieben ist,
ist mein Eindruck bei uns.
Obwohl es natürlich auch dann ja vereinzelt Konflikte gab.
Also die Spannungen sind natürlich offensichtlich auch in Europa überall da,
wo es eine starke muslimische Grundbevölkerung gibt, spielt das Thema natürlich eine riesige Rolle.
Natürlich auch in Berlin und es gibt halt dann ja auch sehr viel Konflikt und
natürlich ist auch die Bedrohungslage für Juden, die in Deutschland leben,
auch nochmal weiter angewachsen dadurch.
Also ihr seht schon, man versucht nur ein paar Aspekte aufzuzählen und es nimmt
irgendwie alles gar kein Ende, wie viel Dimensionen das alles hat.
Und dann eben das ganze auch ethisch aufzudröseln ist ganz schwierig so zu gucken,
auf wessen Seite schlägt man sich jetzt, muss man sich überhaupt auf irgendeine
Seite schlagen, wie ordnet man das für sich selbst einfach im
Kopf einfach das ganze ohne jetzt irgendwie selber den Leuten vielleicht mit
Unrecht zu tun oder sich natürlich entsprechend ja zu Recht auch Kritik einzufangen,
möglicherweise für einen Standpunkt, der ja so vielleicht nicht in Ordnung oder
kritisierbar ist, zu Recht.
Und das ist halt, das Ganze ist halt ein ziemliches Minenfeld,
das haben auch schon ganz viele Leute in den sozialen Medien jetzt mitbekommen,
die sich wirklich teilweise ganz harmlos nur geäußert haben dazu vor allen Dingen
ja auf twitter oder so selbst einfach eine solidaritätsbekundung an israel kann
da im falschen kontext einen shitstorm auslösen.
Und auch die Solidaritätsbemühungen in andere Richtungen.
Egal was man da sagt, man landet sofort in so einem heißen Topf von brudelndem
Öl, ohne sich irgendeiner Schuld vielleicht zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon bewusst
zu sein, klar. Also das ist definitiv ein heißes Eisen.
Und da haben wir gesagt, da machen wir doch mit.
Und auch, aber egal, ob man jetzt sozusagen sich auf die eine Seite oder die
andere Seite oder keine Seite schlägt, das ist dann genau so,
ja, möglicherweise unethisch, ja.
Und da, also was auch noch dazu kommt,
dass viele unserer Quellen, die wir ja sowieso verfolgen, die auch den Ukraine-Konflikt
begleiten, auch durchaus, ja, wertvolles jetzt in der letzten Woche,
finde ich, zu diesem Konflikt gesagt haben.
Und überhaupt, was Wahnsinn ist, wie viele Experten es gibt.
Also dieser Konflikt ist wahrscheinlich auch der,
weiß nicht, wissenschaftlich und politisch einer der am meisten durchleuchteten,
wo man wirklich Experten ohne Ende finden kann,
die auch tatsächlich wirklich viel dazu zu sagen haben, a la couleur.
Ja, aber dort dann auch so ein bisschen den Überblick zu behalten oder irgendwie
eine Linie reinzukriegen, das ist das, was wir versuchen wollen heute.
Und auch ein paar Denkanstöße und ein paar Details vielleicht,
die nicht so allgemein bekannt sind, aber jetzt hochgepoppt sind,
sind zu beleuchten und ja, ich hoffe wir kriegen es einigermaßen hin, wir werden sehen.
Genau, wir haben uns dann überlegt womit fangen wir denn an und ich denke was
in der ganzen Debatte um Israel,
Palästina, den palästinensischen Staat und die ganzen Kriege der letzten Jahre,
Wenn man das alles betrachtet, dann gibt es vor allem erstmal viel Missverständnisse
und sehr viel Unkenntnis.
Und da nehme ich mich auch selbst überhaupt nicht aus. Vielleicht sollten wir
auch generell nochmal diesen Disclaimer hier absetzen, den wir bisher eigentlich immer gebracht haben.
Wir sind keine Experten, sondern wir sind einfach nur Beobachter der Situation.
Wir haben das Gefühl, das betrifft uns, zwar nicht unmittelbar, aber mittelbar.
Es ist sozusagen Teil des gesamten Konfliktraums und wir haben auch schon angedeutet,
dass er sich auch teilweise hier in unsere Gesellschaft überträgt oder wird
er zumindest eine Rolle spielen.
Und wir wissen auch nicht alles, sondern auch wir beschäftigen uns einfach damit,
wir schauen uns das Geschehen an, wir versuchen unsere Wissenslücken zu füllen
und versuchen dabei eine Position einzunehmen,
die das Ganze einfach mit Interesse beobachtet, aber eben vielleicht auch mal
wertet oder auch mal versucht irgendwie zu erklären.
Das ist so ein bisschen unser Ansatz.
Ja und um das jetzt zu erreichen, denke ich,
ist es halt wichtig, dass man erstmal die Grundlagen schafft und deswegen wollen
wir euch mal mit in die Geschichte zurücknehmen,
was glaube ich auch sehr wichtig ist, um einfach auch ein paar Begrifflichkeiten
richtig hinzubekommen, weil einfach vieles da vermischt wird,
auch in der Diskussion oder nicht so genau genommen wird oder mal so oder so interpretiert wird.
Viele Begriffe sind natürlich durch die aktuelle politische Diskussion auch
überladen worden mit der Zeit, bedeuten heute vielleicht etwas anderes,
als sie eigentlich mal bedeutet haben.
All diese Dinge sollten wir uns erstmal zurechtlegen und tja ja,
ich weiß noch, als wir über die Ukraine angefangen haben zu reden,
da sind wir glaube ich so hundert, fünfhundert Jahre zurückgegangen bis zu den Mongolenkriegen.
Okay gut, um einfach erstmal so einen Einstieg zu haben, wo kommt denn das alles so her.
Aber hier, meine Herren, wir rollen jetzt im Prinzip 3000, 4000 Jahre zurück so ungefähr.
Die Besiedlung dieses Gebietes war ja eine sehr frühe,
also das war ja nicht zusammen da mit Syrien auch eine sehr fruchtbare Gegend
und letzten Endes auch die Evolution aus Afrika heraus,
der moderne Mensch, das hat sich ja alles durch diese Gegend herausentwickelt
und von daher war dort schon immer zivilisatorische Entwicklung,
dort hat sich einfach viel getan und dementsprechend ist es auch ein sehr vielfältiger
Ort gewesen, schon immer.
Früh besiedelt und alle Völker, alle Stämme, alle Religionen,
die sich über Jahrhunderte und über Jahrtausende entwickelt haben,
haben in irgendeiner Form dort ein Business gehabt.
Älteste Städte, Jerusalem und andere, das war sozusagen für viele Kulturen,
für viele Religionen, für viele Machthaber, Invasoren immer irgendwie ein wichtiger Ort.
Und aber ich denke, wo wir einsteigen können,
vielleicht ist so 576 vor Christi,
weil ich habe mich gefragt, natürlich bei dem Konflikt,
so, okay, wieso sind die Juden denn in alle Welt verstreut worden und wodurch
eigentlich und wann begann das? und los ging das.
So 576 vor Christi, da fanden die ersten Vertreibungen statt und so ein Höhepunkt,
sagen 63 so vor Christi gab's.
Dann wurde das eigentlich besetzt von den Römern,
Die kommen da ins Spiel und haben dann
von 132 bis 136 nach Christi
Geburt so im Rahmen der Niederschlagung des sogenannten Bar-Koch-Bar-Aufstands
so richtig brutal zugeschlagen dort und die Römer waren ohnehin eine sehr brutale Gesellschaft,
auch im Inneren.
Wenn sie Krieg geführt haben, ja, haben sie im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes oft
keine Gefangenen genommen.
Also es ist sehr bekannt, dass, ja...
Wenn die Römer erst mal so richtig entschlossen waren, dann ein Problem mit
Aufständischen zu lösen, dass die dann im Prinzip zum Genozid gegriffen haben.
Und nicht nur das, in dem Fall war es so,
also es gab
eben vorher mehrere Aufstände schon und so
im Vorfeld von diesem Bar-Koch-Bar-Aufstand wurde erst
mal die Hälfte der römischen Truppen dort überfallen und niedergemetzelt und
daraufhin haben sie dann ja ihre Truppen dort verzehnfacht und sind dann einmal
durchs ganze Land gezogen, haben über 500.000.
Menschen direkt umgebracht oder ja Juden in dem Fall und eine unbekannte Zahl
von Zivilisten noch, ist natürlich durch Hunger, Krankheit und Feuer gestorben.
Es wurden um die 500 Siedlungen dem Boden gleich gemacht,
50 Festungen und wurden Brunnen zerstört und Felder teilweise durch Salz unbrauchbar
gemacht und dann verbleibender Landbesitz wurde dann vom römischen Staat eingezogen und Überlebende,
Wenn sie denn nicht flüchten konnten, wurden zu großer Zahl auch versklavt.
Und um dem noch einen oben drauf zu setzen, so wurde dann das ganze Land auch
noch umbelandt in Palästina von den Römern.
Also so im Rahmen ihrer kolonialen Anstrengungen.
Das heißt Palästina ist eigentlich so ein kolonial geprägter Begriff durch die Römer.
Vorher war es Judäa. Also wir haben sozusagen jetzt knapp 600 vor Christi.
Das war sozusagen diese Eroberung des Babylonischen Königs.
Da wurden sozusagen die Juden das erste Mal in die Diaspora geschickt.
Das hielt dann irgendwie 70 Jahre und später waren es dann halt vor allem die
Römer. Und der Widerstand gegen die Römer hat dann sozusagen diese Zeit geprägt.
Und immer wieder war es halt mit Vertreibung, mit Genozid, mit Vernichtung der
Lebensgrundlagen verbunden.
Also das Volk hat sozusagen schon immer ordentlich einen abbekommen aus allen Seiten.
Ja, Bar Kochbar hieß der Aufstand übrigens, weil Bar Kochbar war der Anführer
dieses Aufstands. Simon Bar Kochbar hat damals halt eine wichtige...
Rolle gespielt hat.
Genau, und seitdem wurde das halt entweder von den Römern beherrscht,
dann von hinterher von Byzanz.
Dann gab es zwischendurch auch kurz die Sassaniden, die ein bisschen in Vergessenheit
geraten sind, dann die Araber, dann kam das Osmanische Reich und dann die Briten.
Da haben sich eben auch ganz schön viele Imperialisten abgewechselt,
sag ich mal, beim Herrschen über diese Gegend.
Genau und es gab vor allem auch schon immer diese multireligiöse Präsenz,
neben den Juden und Arabern dann halt auch noch Christen natürlich und Drusen,
die einen kleinen Anteil ja auch immer noch ausmachen.
Vielleicht nochmal so ein Hinweis zu dieser Namensgebung, weil das ist so das,
was ich am Anfang meinte, wo oft die Begriffe ein wenig durcheinander gebracht
werden. Also Palästina ist quasi ein durch die Römer geprägter Name.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie den her haben.
Vorher war es halt irgendwie Judea und es bezeichnete halt nicht etwa jetzt
einen Staat, sondern einfach das Land.
Palästina ist halt einfach diese gesamte Region von den Römern eben so genannt worden.
Ja, also wir hatten jetzt sozusagen in der Folgezeit diverse jüdisch-königreiche,
aber eben auch eine schon anwachsende jüdisch durch die Vertreibung,
durch diese vielfältige Vertreibung auch so eine internationale jüdische Verbreitung.
Also dass sozusagen die Juden nicht nur an diesem Ort waren,
sondern immer wieder durch diese Konflikte auch an andere Stellen der Erde vertrieben
wurden. Das war sozusagen ein wiederkehrendes Element der Geschichte.
Und das ging im Prinzip so richtig los mit dokumentierter Verfolgung und Vertreibung.
Ging es wohl 1492, hauptsächlich aus Spanien, wo sich eben auch größere jüdische
Siedlungen, Bevölkerungsgruppen befanden.
Das ging über mehrere hundert Jahre, stückweise, bis dann irgendwann auch im 18.
Jahrhundert ging das dann los mit Migration aus Osteuropa,
vor allem in westeuropäische und dann amerikanische Metropolen,
einerseits getrieben durch dann eben auch Pogrome in den Ländern,
aber auch dadurch, dass die Menschen dann einfach in Juden dann sich in westeuropäischen
und amerikanischen Metropolen zum großen Teil angesiedelt haben,
auch im Rahmen von Industrialisierung und generell Versteterung.
Und so richtig unangenehm wird es dann aber nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg eigentlich
für die Juden überall dann die Vertreibung aus.
Osteuropa nochmal richtig ja an Intensität zu um dann ja in der Shoah im Holocaust,
im Massenmord, im industrialisierten Massenmord durch die Nazis dann ihren Höhepunkt zu erreichen.
Ja, man fragt sich natürlich, warum trifft es eigentlich immer die Juden so?
Du hast jetzt mit Spanien angefangen, es gab es auch schon früher,
gab es schon in England, gab es in Frankreich.
Immer gab es wieder so irgendwelche Edikte von Königen, die dann einfach gesagt haben,
geht mal bitte alle weg und ich denke man kann, das ist ein sehr einfacher Erklärungsversuch,
aber es hat halt im Wesentlichen einfach immer was mit diesem Religionskonflikt zu tun.
Kirchen, Religionen spielten natürlich in den Staaten damals noch mehr eine
große Rolle als heute und war sozusagen immer auf Staatsebene angesiedelt,
weil wer sozusagen Herrscher über die Gedanken ist, der ist auch Herrscher über die Menschen.
Und da passte natürlich eine alternative Religion, die so jetzt mit der eigenen
Prägung nichts zu tun hatte, nichts rein.
Und die Juden, die halt dann ihre eigenen Subgesellschafteten dort ausbildeten,
waren dann halt einfach irgendwann der Feind, weil ja, andere Religionen und
dann reicht das meistens dann auch schon als Erklärung.
Religion ist eigentlich immer mit Herrschaft und Politik verknüpft und existiert
eigentlich in einer Symbiose und ist nur schwer voneinander zu trennen tatsächlich.
Und ohne Staat, ohne eigenen Staat, merkte man dann, wird es halt immer wieder
unangenehm für so eine Volksgruppe.
Und ja, spätestens natürlich nach eben dem Holocaust war endgültig klar,
dass die Juden irgendwie schon vielleicht einen eigenen Staat irgendwo haben sollten.
Also wenn dann, also die Nazis haben eigentlich da eines der besten Argumente
für die Notwendigkeit eines jüdischen Staates geschaffen mit dem Holocaust.
Wobei jetzt die Idee nicht erst in dem Moment aufkam, sondern die Bewegung des Zionismus,
das bezieht sich halt auf den Berg Zion in Jerusalem,
sozusagen die Heimstätte des ersten Tempels, sozusagen der Inbegriff der Geburt
oder der Manifestation der jüdischen Religion, so kann man das glaube ich in etwa beschreiben.
Das war sozusagen eine Idee, die von Juden weltweit vorangetrieben wurde,
eben zu sagen, hör mal, wir haben überall Ärger, wir werden immer wieder verjagt,
wir brauchen Land an unserem Ursprungsort.
Wir müssen dort sein und wir müssen dort einen Staat haben, sonst wird es für
uns nie Sicherheit geben.
Und diese Bewegung kam halt so im 19. Jahrhundert schon auf, also Ende des 19.
Jahrhunderts und wurde dann eben so von verschiedensten Leuten vorangetrieben.
Theodor Herzl war so der Begründer der modernen zionistischen Bewegung und hat
halt sozusagen diese Idee des Judenstaats geboren.
Dann wurde das aber im internationalen Spiel der Kräfte immer wieder verschoben.
Damals war dann eben das Gebiet, nennen wir es jetzt mal Palästina.
Wie gesagt, es ist jetzt kein Staat, sondern es ist einfach die Region.
Und alle, die quasi dort leben und gelebt haben, in dem Sinne Palästinenser.
Wurde halt von vom osmanischen reich besetzt gehalten also die kräfte spiele
also wir wollen jetzt hier keinen kompletten historischen diskurs machen mit
wer wann wo wen angegriffen und überfallen hat und so weiter dann sitzen wir hier noch 30 stunden.
Aber das ist sozusagen das Ding. Wurde dann aber im Rahmen der Beutezüge der
Briten 1917 dann eben in britisches Gebiet überführt.
Also die Briten haben letztlich dann die Osmanen dort vertrieben und sich dieser
Gebiete angenommen, zu Protektoraten umgebaut.
Quasi Kolonien, die sie nicht so nennen wollten. Und um aber die Osmanen dort
vertreiben zu können, haben sie sich sozusagen sowohl mit den Juden als auch
mit den Arabern dort verbündet.
Und letzten Endes auch beiden quasi versprochen, hier hör mal,
wenn ihr uns helft hier die Osmanen zu vertreiben, dann fällt da auch Land für
euch bei ab. Das war so ein bisschen das Versprechen.
Ja und um es auch nochmal vielleicht ein bisschen zu präzisieren,
was eigentlich jetzt Palästina umfasst, das sind eben die Gebiete der heutigen
Staaten Israel und Jordanien und einschließlich eben Gaza-Streifen und Westjordanland.
Also es ist jetzt nicht nur Israel und die sogenannten Palästinenser-Gebiete,
sondern Jordanien gehört auch dazu.
Genau und wahrscheinlich auch noch so ein Eckchen von Syrien und so weiter,
das ist ja Libanon und so, das sind fließende Übergänge aber im Prinzip wir
reden genau von diesem Bereich.
Aber jetzt befinden wir uns sozusagen ja noch im ersten Weltkrieg und dort ändern
sich dann halt einfach die Machtverhältnisse und es gab dann auch schon von
Großbritannien aus eine Anerkennung dieser Idee,
dass es eine nationale Heimstätte für das jüdische Volk geben sollte.
Das ist die sogenannte Balfour Declaration, die damals dort in Großbritannien
entstanden ist und aus der heraus,
nicht nur aus der heraus, hat sich sozusagen generell diese Idee entwickelt,
dass es halt eine Lösung geben muss für dieses Gebiet.
Und das ist dann 1920 in das sogenannte Völkerbundsmandat für Palästina übergegangen.
Der Völkerbund war quasi so ein bisschen der Vorläufer der Vereinten Nationen
kann man glaube ich sagen.
Und das war halt im Prinzip auch eine Feststellung, dass eben dieses jetzt unter
britischem Mandat stehende Gebiet in irgendeiner Form halt eine Lösung braucht.
Und dort halt auch sowohl für die Juden als auch für die Araber eine Lösung zu finden sei.
Und Ryan Macbeth sagte so schön, traue niemals einem Briten mit einem Stift der Linien auf Karten,
zieht, ja das vielleicht dazu.
So aber hier zeigt sich sozusagen die Idee ist eine sehr alte und sie existierte
im Prinzip auch schon und diese Forderung existierte auch schon vor dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Aber wie du vorhin schon richtig gesagt hast, hat das natürlich durch den zweiten
Weltkrieg nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung bekommen.
In dieser Zeit, in den 20er und in den 30er Jahren, hat sich auch eine Menge
getan, weil es gab schon eine zunehmende Einwanderung der Juden in dieses Gebiet.
Also das kann ich jetzt ein bisschen schwer einschätzen, was da der primäre Faktor war,
aber dieser kollektive Wunsch der Juden international an diesem Ort in irgendeiner
Form zu einer staatlichen Lösung zu kommen, hat eben auch viele,
glaube ich, auf die Reise geschickt, dort einfach mitzuwirken, da dran.
Und das hat dann auch schon immer so ein bisschen für Spannungen gesorgt.
Ich habe hier mal eine Zahl gefunden, die so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür gibt,
wie das damals war. So 1922 ist dort das erste Mal so eine Zählung vorgenommen
worden. Da gab es so einen Zensus.
Und in dieser Region gab es damals ungefähr 590.000 Muslime,
84.000 Juden, 73.000 Christen, 7.000 Trusen, so in der Größenordnung.
Also klar noch eine Mehrheit von Muslimen, aber wie gesagt, in den 20er und
30er Jahren gab es dann einfach eine zunehmende Einwanderungsbewegung.
Vor allem auch aus Russland, von russischen Juden, aber im Prinzip von überall.
Und das hat schon immer zu Spannungen geführt.
Es gab auch verschiedene Angriffe, unter anderem das Massaker von Hebron 1929.
Also die Konflikte vor Ort waren auf jeden Fall auch immer schon da.
Aber nichts hat natürlich so sehr die Problematik wieder auf den Tisch gebracht,
wie die Shoah, wie die Israelis das nennen,
der Holocaust, also die Vernichtung, industrielle Vernichtung muss man schon fast sagen,
von Juden durch die Nazis und danach war halt einfach mal klar,
dass die Juden einen eigenen Staat brauchten und so wie auch nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg halt die Vereinten Nationen hervorgegangen sind aus dem Völkerbund,
wo man gesagt hat, wir brauchen jetzt mal so eine internationale,
naja Governance will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber wir brauchen sozusagen einen
Internationalismus, der in irgendeiner Form dazu beitragen kann,
unsere internationalen Konflikte zu lösen.
Das funktioniert hat, darüber kann man jetzt geteilter Meinung sein,
aber das war die Motivation für die Gründung der Vereinten Nationen,
der UN, die sich 1945 dann halt auch wirklich nach dem Krieg herausgebildet hat.
Und eine der ersten Maßnahmen der UN war dann eben zwei Jahre später der sogenannte UN-Teilungsplan,
also ein konkreter Vorschlag darüber, wie denn jetzt hier die palästinensischen
Gebiete, Palästina, aufgeteilt werden soll zwischen jüdischen und arabischen Bevölkerungsgruppen.
Naja, und eigentlich war da zu dem Zeitpunkt aber das Kind schon halb in den Brunnen gefallen,
weil in dem Moment auch so ein bisschen offensichtlich wurde,
dass diese beiden Gruppen, also dass vor allem Juden und Muslime nicht zusammen
in einem Staat leben können.
Und Problem natürlich damals dann dann auch wären so ein bisschen die Mehrheitsverhältnisse gewesen so,
weil dann eben Angst hatte, dass wenn man dann so,
wenn alle in einem Staat zusammen sind, dass dann ja die Muslime einfach ja
die Juden dominieren werden.
Aber das eigentliche Problem war halt die Gewalt der Jahrzehnte,
wie du schon sagtest, irgendwie das Massaker von Hebron und so.
Bereits 1947, sozusagen, der Teilungsplan wurde vor dem Hintergrund entwickelt,
dass man das Gefühl hatte, die können nicht in einem Staat leben.
Ja, das denke ich, muss man auch festhalten, so dass das ja damals schon nicht
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen war, sondern irgendwie schon damals versuchen musste
irgendwie einen Kompromiss oder eher die auseinander zu dividieren.
Der Teilungsplan hat halt gesagt, dass ungefähr 56 Prozent des Territoriums
jüdischem Staat zugeschlagen werden soll, 43 Prozent eben einem arabischen Staat.
Wie es zu dieser Nicht-Fifty-Fifty-Lösung gekommen ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber so war das.
Und dazu kommt eben auch noch die internationale Verwaltung für Jerusalem,
weil Jerusalem liegt dann so quasi in diesem arabischen Teil und es war natürlich
klar, dass man jetzt Jerusalem so als Hochburg multireligiöser Präsenz so nicht
einem zuschlagen konnte.
Weißt du, wie warst du mal in Jerusalem?
Aber du warst schon mal in Israel?
Nein, aber ich habe eine Reihe von Freundenleben dort, mit denen ich auch in Verbindung stehe.
Also ich war einmal in Jerusalem und zweimal, dreimal in Israel.
Und Jerusalem ist schon wirklich beeindruckend.
Wie, ich weiß nicht, überall in Jerusalem. Ich hab mir vor allem natürlich das Zentrum angeschaut,
was ja sozusagen so der Inbegriff dieser Vierteiligkeit ist zwischen den einzelnen
Religionsgruppen, weil ja sowohl Araber als auch Juden als auch Drusen als auch
Christen dort sozusagen ihre Präsenz haben.
Ich hatte so den Eindruck, man spürt die Geschichte, man spürt den Konflikt,
man spürt aber auch irgendwie das, was eigentlich dort alle gemeinsam haben könnten.
Aber trotzdem hat es halt nicht funktioniert. Egal, zurück zu diesem Teilungsplan.
Es gab die notwendige Zweidrittelmehrheit, aber diese Zweidrittelmehrheit,
die bestand halt im Wesentlichen aus den Großmächten USA, Russland,
diverse lateinamerikanische, natürlich europäische Länder.
Aber es stimmten natürlich auch 13 Länder dagegen.
Und das waren vor allem arabische, muslimische Länder, aber auch Griechenland,
Indien und ein paar haben sich enthalten.
Mit anderen Worten, die Resolution wurde angenommen, mehr oder weniger beschlossen,
aber der arabische Teil war eigentlich nicht glücklich mit dieser Aufteilung.
Und zwar aus tausend Gründen wahrscheinlich. Also, ob es nun der Anteil ist
oder die Tatsache, dass man dort überhaupt versucht eine Teilung vorzunehmen.
Aber es gab halt zu diesem Zeitpunkt weder einen arabischen Staat,
an diesem Ort noch einen jüdischen Staat. Man sieht das ja oft,
dass dieser Zeitpunkt sozusagen genommen wird, als das war damals Palästina
und dann ist die Hälfte davon den Juden gegeben worden.
Mit dieser Implikation, dass Palästina das ist, was man heute unter Palästina versteht.
Aber es ist halt Palästina das Gebiet und nicht der Staat. Und man hat versucht
dort zwei Staaten daraus zu machen.
Ja, dann kam es halt 1948, 14. Mai, kam es zur Gründung Israels auf Basis eben
dieses beschlossenen Teilungsplans.
Ja, dann dauerte es auch nicht lange und es gab den ersten israelischen-arabischen Krieg,
weil unmittelbar nach dieser Unabhängigkeitserklärung Ägypten,
Jordanien, Syrien, der Irak und der Libanon,
also mit anderen Worten alle Nachbarn Israels plus der Irak,
griffen mit dem,
was sie militärisch zur Verfügung hatten, Israel an und wollten sozusagen verhindern,
dass dieser israelische Staat in irgendeiner Form existiert oder,
wie Sie das offiziell gesagt haben, Sie wollten die palästinensische Bevölkerung
vor einem zionistischen Staat schützen.
Ja, oder man könnte auch sagen, Sie wollten die Juden ins Meer zurücktreiben und,
ja, daraus werfen, aus Palästina Israel, also Israel vernichten,
kann man ganz klar sagen. A.
Genau, das sah auch erst mal danach aus, als ob sie da Fortschritte erzielen.
Sie haben dann also Geländegewinne gemacht, aber die israelische Verteidigung,
die IDF, die konnte sie dann aufhalten und zurückdrücken und hat dann nach diversen
Offensiven diese ganzen Gebiete wieder zurückgeholt und hat dann selber ihr besetztes Gebiet,
also in diesem Krieg besetztes Gebiet, über das von diesem UN-Teilungsplan vorgesehene
Gebiet hinaus erweitert.
Also vorher hatten sie darauf keinen Anspruch erhoben, sondern haben nur im
Rahmen dieses Krieges dann weitere Gebiete besetzt.
Das ging dann noch eine Weile weiter, es gab zwar einen Waffenstillstand,
aber es wurde dann weiter gekämpft und das ging dann irgendwie bis 49,
Anfang 1949, ja, womit dann Israel ein Gebiet kontrollierte,
was etwas größer war, als der Teilungsplan das vorher gesehen hat.
Und die haben sie dann auch erst mal aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht hergegeben.
Ja und jetzt sind wir im Prinzip in dieser ganzen Kriegskonfliktlogik,
die sich seitdem so weiterentwickelt hat.
Es ging dann weiter, 1956 ausgelöst durch die Pläne Gibbens,
den Suezkanal zu nationalisieren, der war nämlich vorher quasi unter britisch-französischer Kontrolle.
Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass Israel den Suez angegriffen hat.
Das war dann wiederum nicht so erfolgreich, weil halt die Großmächte gesagt
haben, wir wollen hier irgendwie keinen Ärger haben und dann mussten halt auch
Frankreich und Großbritannien sich da zurückziehen.
Da haben die USA glaube ich vor allem, da sind da reingegrätscht.
Also das war definitiv eine Niederlage. Mir ist ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz klar,
warum Israel sich da überhaupt genötigt gesehen hat, hier die Interessen Großbritanniens,
Frankreichs da zu vertreten.
Das macht auf mich den Eindruck ein Fehler gewesen zu sein.
Ja, ich meine diese US-Kanal-Geschichte, da kann man auch Stunden drüber reden,
was das für eine üble Nummer war, weil ja,
ich meine Frankreich und Großbritannien hatten den glaube ich hauptsächlich finanziert,
beziehungsweise, was heißt finanziert, also haben dann schon den Ägyptern ziemlich
viele Schulden auch auferlegt.
Und die dann nicht bezahlen konnten, worauf sie sich dann den Suezkanal unter
den Nagel gerissen haben,
woraufhin dann irgendwann aber die Ägypter gesagt haben, irgendwie nee,
so nicht und dann quasi diese Enteignung rückgängig gemacht haben, ganz grob gesagt.
Aber ja, auch eine krasse Geschichte, aber das würde jetzt glaube ich zu weit führen.
Aber es fand auf jeden Fall statt und gilt so ein bisschen als zweiter israelisch-arabischer Krieg.
Ja, und dann kam es zu einem weiteren Krieg.
Der ja somit zu den größten und wichtigsten Wendepunkten, glaube ich,
auch gehört in dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Der sogenannte Sechstagekrieg im Juni 1967,
ausgelöst durch das Skippen,
den Golf von Aqaba, gesperrt hat für israelische Schiffe und das hat dann Israel
irgendwie als kriegerischen Akt angesehen wiederum mit präventiven Luftangriffen
gegen die ägyptische Luftwaffe geantwortet.
Erste Erfolge erzielt und dann Jordanien, Syrien und den Irak angegriffen und
dann von den Nachbarländern diverse weitere Gebiete erobert.
Unter anderem halt die komplette Sinai-Halbinsel und den Gaza-Streifen,
der halt damals noch zu Ägypten gehörte.
Und natürlich die sogenannte Westbank, einschließlich der Osten von Jerusalem,
der damals noch zu Jordanien gehörte, und die Golanhöhen von Syrien. BK'IN DR.
MERKEL. Ja. Also, vielleicht mal nochmal betonen, weil du sagst,
dass also Gaza zu Ägypten gehört, ist vielleicht auch noch ein wichtiges Detail.
Also, es gehörte in dem Sinne nicht zu Ägypten, sondern wurde halt im Wesentlichen
ja von Ägypten verwaltet, sagen wir es mal so.
Genau, so wie die Westbank, glaube ich, von Jordanien verwaltet wurde,
also insofern, ja,
hatten da zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte Israel dort in diesen Gegenden selber nichts zu melden,
sage ich mal, bis, ja, bis zu dem Punkt,
eben bis zu diesem Krieg, wo sie, ja, Dann selber jetzt,
wo dann Israel die Verantwortung letztlich für den Gazastreifen und für die
Westbank übernommen hat, wenn man das so will.
Also die ganzen Geländegewinne oder Landnamen Israels sind immer verbunden mit diesen Kriegen.
Man kann sich halt darüber unterhalten, wer am Ende dann wirklich der legitime
Auslöser dieser Konflikte gewesen ist,
weil das ist ja auch nicht immer alles so, dass es so von heute auf morgen aus
dem helligsten Tag heraus passiert, sondern das sind ja immer alles kleine Schritte
hier und dort und Vorkommnis, die dann eben irgendwann zu einer Eskalation führen.
Aber ich denke, damit ist dieser Sechstagekrieg ganz gut beschrieben und vor
allem stand nach diesem Sechstagekrieg Israel einfach auch als klare militärische
Macht in dieser Region fest.
Also sie haben also mühelos mehrere Angreifer, also in dem Fall waren es ja Jordanien, Syrien.
Und Irak, die angegriffen wurden, hatten sie halt unter Kontrolle und das war
halt entscheidend. BK'IN DR.
Also auch und auch bemerkenswert, dass so ein kleines Land wie Israel mit einigen
Millionen Einwohnern zu dem Zeitpunkt ja ungefähr,
ich glaube, weiß nicht 400 Millionen Arabern Gegenüber stand so größenordnungsmäßig
und ja, die alle militärisch besiegt hat.
Nicht ganz ohne Hilfe, aber letztlich schon.
Und das war natürlich eine furchtbare Demütigung, auch dann für die ganzen Araber.
So und jetzt gut zu den Gründen, vielleicht später noch kommen.
Aber ein Detail fällt mir gerade noch ein, weil wir mehrfach jetzt die Westbank
erwähnt hatten und was immer ein bisschen verwirrend ist,
ist, dass die Westbank im Osten von Israel ist und die heißt halt Westbank,
weil es das Westufer des Jordan ist.
Aber ja, das nur so noch als geografische Information vielleicht dazu.
Ja, das stimmt.
Westbank oder Westjordanland sozusagen.
Ja und dann kommen wir zu einem Krieg, der jetzt in der aktuellen Situation
auch nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung hat. Das ist nämlich genau 50 Jahre her.
Im Oktober 1973, der sogenannte Yom Kippur Krieg.
Es ist Feiertag der Israelis und hier gab es eben einen Überraschungsangriff,
der wiederum von den arabischen Staaten ausging.
In dem Fall war es ein Angriff von Ägypten und Syrien, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und auch das hat halt damals die Israelis so ein bisschen auf dem linken Fuß erwischt.
Also sie haben sozusagen mit diesem Angriff so nicht gerechnet.
Und ja, waren dann sozusagen erstmal ziemlich unter Druck,
haben es dann geschafft, nachdem Ägypten und Syrien so einige militärische Erfolge
erzielt haben, die dann auch wiederum zurückzudrängen und eine Gegenoffensive zu starten.
Und ja dann gab es irgendwann nach ein paar Wochen gab es einen Waffenstillstand,
so mit dem das erstmal so ausgegangen ist.
Also das war trotzdem Israel sich wehren konnte, wurde das so ein bisschen als
politischer Sieg für Ägypten gewertet, einfach weil sie überhaupt in der Lage
waren israelische Linien zu durchbrechen.
Merkt schon da gibt es so ein Pattern was jetzt wieder auftritt. Genau.
Ja und was vielleicht auch,
zum einen gibt es nicht nur diese zeitliche Anknüpfung,
sondern auch eben andere Parallelen, dass Israel völlig überrascht war und es
gab dann auch eine Untersuchung,
wie es dazu kommen konnte, dass man nichts davon wusste, dass sie jetzt kommen
würden und die Gründe, mal später noch, sind,
waren damals ähnliche, warum man nicht damit gerechnet hat damals.
Nämlich auch eine gewisse Überheblichkeit,
Unterschätzung, Unterschätzen der Feinde und eben auch ein falsches Einordnen
von Geheimdienstinformationen,
die man zwar hatte, aber nicht geglaubt hat, dass sie sich das trauen,
so einfach denen das nicht zugetraut hat.
Obwohl man wusste, dass sie es können und dass da was tut, dass da Truppen aufmarschiert
sind. Aber man dachte dann halt, naja, das sind halt reine Drogebärden und die
werden schon nicht kommen.
Und ein anderes Ding, was man noch zum Jom Kippur-Krieg erwähnen sollte,
ist, dass es damals um ein Haar auch zu einer nuklearen Eskalation gekommen ist.
Sowohl die Sowjetunion wollte taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen zu dem Zeitpunkt und ja,
also da ging ziemlich viel dann im Hintergrund auch zwischen den USA und der
Sowjetunion damals an Diplomatie,
um eben einen Atomkrieg abzuwenden, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt Israel selber auch
bereits schon Atomwaffen hatte.
Und in dem Zusammenhang, wie gesagt, das war gefährlich damals.
Also gefährlicher, als wir uns das heute so allgemein bewusst sind,
dass damals auch die Welt kurz vor einem Atomkrieg im Nahen Osten stand.
Der Yom Kippur-Krieg ist auch noch in einer anderen Hinsicht dann ganz interessant,
wenn man jetzt auf die politische Lage blickt.
Damals hieß die Ministerpräsidentin Golda Meir, die ja durchaus ihre Meriten
für Israel hat und eigentlich eher,
soweit ich das beurteilen kann, halbwegs populäre Ministerpräsidentin auch gewesen
ist, aber halt in diesem Konflikt falsche Entscheidungen gefällt hat.
Auch hier wurden Geheimdienstinformationen ignoriert.
Es wurde eben kein früher Gegenschlag beschlossen und das führte dann eben dazu
und später musste sie im nächsten Jahr schon zurücktreten.
Also das ist natürlich jetzt im Blick auf die aktuelle Regierung der Tanjau.
Dazu werden wir dann gleich noch ausführlich kommen. Auch nochmal eine ganz
interessante Geschichte.
Ja, dann gibt es jetzt erstmal keinen neuen Krieg, sondern wir springen ein
bisschen in die nächste Zeit. 1978 gab es das sogenannte Camp David Abkommen.
Und das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, für mich auch ein interessantes Datum,
weil so in meinem Leben war das somit das erste, was ich damals so von diesem
Konflikt mitgenommen habe.
Also ich bin ja 1967 geboren, also das war sozusagen als ich vier Jahre alt
war, aber daran kann ich mich irgendwie noch erinnern. Das war so auf einmal
Teil meiner medialen Wahrnehmung.
Damals war das halt ein großes Ding.
Menachem Begin und Anwar Sadat, der Führer Ägyptens, die waren halt dort,
sozusagen Kim Davids, dieser Landsitz des US-Präsidenten.
Ja, und unter der Vermittlung von Jimmy Carter wurde eben eine Friedensverhandlung
geführt und ein Friedensabkommen auch geschlossen, was dann eben so ein bisschen
zur Aussöhnung zwischen Ägypten und Israel geführt hat.
Man hat also einfach eingesehen, das geht jetzt nicht so weiter,
das führt zu gar nichts und immerhin gab es dann mal hier den ersten Friedensschluss
zwischen einem arabischen Nachbarland von Israel und Israel selber.
Wobei man vielleicht, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was die Rolle von Jordanien
dann später noch war, ob die sich zu dem Zeitpunkt da auch schon befriedet haben.
Schauen wir gleich nochmal.
Auf jeden Fall drei Jahre später wurde Anwar Sadat ermordet.
Und zwar bei so einer Militärparade in Ägypten, in Kairo glaube ich irgendwo.
Und die haben sich da gerade schön die vorbeifahrenden Militärfahrzeuge angeschaut
und dann gab es aber so eine Assaultgroup, die ihn dann einfach mal niedergeschossen hat.
Und das ist so ein Muster, was wir in diesem Konflikt auch öfter sehen können,
dass diejenigen auf allen Seiten, die irgendwie sich um Frieden bemühen oder
gar Frieden schließen oder Abkommen schließen,
die ja speziell natürlich bei Extremisten auf beiden Seiten hochgradig unbeliebt
sind und ja vielfach dann Attentaten zum Opfer gefallen sind.
Also sich dort für Frieden einzusetzen als Politiker, egal auf welcher Seite,
ja ist in hohem Maße ungesund.
Im Übrigen gilt das sogar auch für Hamas-Führer.
Da in der Hamas, wobei die dann durch Israel überwiegend eliminiert worden sind,
aber das kommen wir vielleicht auch noch später zu.
Ja, das geht ja dann auch so weiter. Also 1993 gab es dann wiederum Friedensgespräche,
damals in Oslo, Norwegen, die geführt wurden mit dem Versuch eine Zwei-Staaten-Lösung
dann doch nochmal irgendwann zu erzielen zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern.
Hier waren die treibenden Kräfte Yitzhak Rabin auf der israelischen Seite und
Yasser Arafat, sozusagen der große Arafat für die palästinensische Bewegung.
Wichtige Person, der Vorsitzende der sogenannten Palästinensischen Befreiungsorganisation,
der PLO, die ja am Anfang noch, sagen wir mal, eher auch so einen terroristischen
Hintergrund hatte und sich dann zunehmend zu einer politischen Organisation entwickelt hat.
Und ja, Arafat und Rabin haben halt dort versucht, so einen Friedensschluss zu finden.
Also Arafat war ein Großteil meiner Jugend einfach das Gesicht der Palästinenser schlechthin,
eine sehr ikonische Figur mit diesem typischen Palästinenser-Tuch und ja,
das war halt sozusagen das Gesicht Palästinas.
Und eben die Fatah, vielleicht ja auch damals nicht alles gesuchte Terroristen.
Wie im Übrigen jetzt bei Terrorismus sind auch ein Großteil der späteren israelischen
Regierungsmitglieder waren lange Zeit gesuchte Terroristen und als sie dann
Staatsmänner wurden mussten dann in einigen Ländern erst mal Gesetze geändert werden,
damit die überhaupt einreisen dürfen, weil sie noch auf Terrorlisten standen.
Zu dem Thema Terrorismus denke ich, kommen wir dann auch noch, aber.
Die Fatah kann man politisch als nationalistische Organisation sehen, also die sozusagen,
ja, so etwas wie die eine palästinensische Nation oder arabische Nation von
Palästinensern als politisches Ziel hatten,
während jetzt die heute aktiven Gruppen wie Hamas halt islamistisch sind.
Das heißt jetzt nicht speziell politisch auf Palästina gemünzt,
sondern eben pan-arabisch oder eben ja vor allen Dingen religiös motiviert,
also islamistisch eben sind im Gegensatz zur nationalistischen Fatah.
Ich habe gerade mal geschaut, also die Fatah muss man dazu sagen,
die Fatah war sozusagen eine Gruppe, die sich mit anderen Gruppen zusammen zu
dieser PLO, zu diesem Dachverband zusammengeschlossen hat.
Er war zwar, Arafat war sowohl Chef der PLO, aber eben auch Chef der Fatah,
also Fatah war sozusagen so seine Gruppe und mit anderen Gruppen,
ja haben sie dort sozusagen da eine Rolle gespielt.
Da gibt es dann halt noch die Volksfront für die Befreiung Palästinas und die
demokratische Front zur Befreiung Palästinas und die palästinensische Volksbefreiung,
wer schon mal viele Monty Python gesehen hat.
Volksfront von Judäa und jüdische Volksfront.
Also das war schon immer alles sehr vielfältig dort und sagt auch glaube ich
einiges darüber aus, dass es da nicht so die eine Wahrnehmung gibt.
Es gibt einfach viele Gruppen, die alle irgendwie unterschiedliche radikale oder offene,
weltoffene Prägungen haben und es ist nicht so einfach dort eine Allianz von
Kräften zusammen zu bekommen, die sowohl eine Mehrheit hat als sich auch in
irgendeiner Form zentral führen lässt.
Das ist auch in Israel ja heute nicht anders.
Also auch die ganzen Regierungen in Israel sind immer von sehr breiten Koalitionen getragen,
weil sie das müssen, weil es einfach so viele Splittergruppen gibt,
die so sehr viel unterschiedliche Sichtweisen und Weltsichten vereinen müssen,
um in irgendeiner Form überhaupt was auf der Kette zu kriegen.
Das war jetzt sozusagen die Friedensgespräche in Oslo. Die haben dann auch tatsächlich
eben dazu geführt, dass es eben diese palästinensische Autonomiegebiete dort dann gibt.
Das war jetzt noch keine Staatenlösung, das war sozusagen so ein Vorläufer davon.
So hat man das halt irgendwie gesehen.
Und Arafat hat das halt irgendwie angeführt und das war dann so ein bisschen
so die Vorstellung eigentlich der Welt,
dass man so jetzt doch weitermachen könnte, um dann sozusagen hier wirklich
mal zu einer Zwei-Staaten-Lösung zu kommen und quasi diese palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde quasi so eine Vorstufe, so eine staatliche Vorstufe sein könnte.
Zwei Jahre später wurde dann Yitzhak Rabin ermordet in Israel.
Also das, was wir vorher schon bei den Ägyptern gesehen haben mit Sadat,
das ist dann halt in Israel passiert.
Also dadurch ist natürlich dann auch diese Friedensbewegung sozusagen im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes unter Beschuss gekommen.
Also es ist immer ein Hin und Her und wer auch immer versucht hier für die Lösung
des Konfliktes zu werben, ist sofort auch Feinde im eigenen Lager.
Es ist ja wirklich schlimm.
Die ganze Zeit, so ab Ende der 80er Jahre bis so mit in die Zehnerjahre rein
oder in die Nullerjahre rein, Entschuldigung.
Dann auch geprägt von Aufständen in den palästinensischen Autonomiegebieten.
Jetzt muss man vorsichtig sein mit den Begrifflichkeiten.
Also sage ich mal, der arabisch-palästinensischen Bevölkerung,
die halt mit dem Gebaren der Israelis ihre Probleme hatten.
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch Teil der Geschichte, dass eben diese immer wieder
von weiterhin von Israel besetzt gehaltenen
Gebiete natürlich auch eine Machtungleichheit zur Schau gestellt hat.
Wo die Israelis gesagt haben, wie der Hase läuft und es eben mit der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung der Freiheit und den Menschenrechten der arabischen Bevölkerung
dann nicht so weit her war.
Das hat dann eben zu diesen Aufständen geführt, dauerhaften Aufstandszuständen der Intifada.
Die erste Intifada ging so 1987 los bis 1993, die zweite ungefähr so 2000 bis
2005. Das waren also fortwährend Bilder, Steine schmeißende Gruppen,
immer wieder Angriffe, einzelne Terroranschläge etc.
Das Ganze dann wiederum gefolgt mit entsprechenden Vergeltungsmaßnahmen der
israelischen Armee, wo dann Häuser mit Bulldozern plattgemacht werden und andere Gräulichkeiten.
Davon war einfach diese ganze Zeit geprägt.
Und am Ende dieser Entwicklung stand dann aber irgendwann auch die Einsicht in Israel,
dass man einfach jetzt vielleicht auch mal Konzession machen muss und in irgendeiner
Form hier den Palästinensern ein Angebot machen muss.
Und daraufhin haben haben sie sich 2005 aus dem Gaza-Streifen komplett zurückgezogen.
Und ja, sozusagen mit der Idee, so nach dem Motto hier, habt ihr Gaza,
macht doch jetzt, was ihr wollt, wir sind jetzt hier raus, vielleicht ist ja dann Ruhe.
Und dann wurde auch im Rahmen von Oslo diese palästinensische Autonomiebehörde gegründet,
wo man dann hoffte, dass die vor allem durch die PLO dann dominiert würde,
die mit am Verhandlungstisch saß.
Aber bei den ersten demokratischen Wahlen,
glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, ob es die ersten die zweiten demokratischen wahlen
dann in in gasa waren ist halt
die hamas dann ja hat
die hat die mehrheit bekommen und kaum
waren sie gewählt haben sie ja die vertrag aus dem gasa streifen vertrieben
also haben dann jagd im prinzip auf vertrag vertreter und plo gemacht und sagen
die macht im gasa streifen Ich glaube das war gleich die erste Wahl 2006.
Und 2007 haben sie dann sozusagen die politisch missliebigen Palästinenser aus Gaza vertrieben,
sodass man jetzt auf einmal die Situation hatte, dass Israel auf der einen Seite
das Westjordanland, die Westbank hatte mit der PLO, mittlerweile mit dem Abbas,
Arafat ist ja dann irgendwann gestorben.
Oder ermordet worden.
Oder ermordet. Also er war auf jeden Fall dann irgendwann tot.
Und Abbas hat das übernommen und hat diese Rolle ja auch heute noch.
Aber die konnten halt mit der Hamas gar nichts anfangen. Warum?
Warum? Weil die Hamas halt nicht
einfach eine weitere Organisation des palästinensischen Widerstands war,
wie das sozusagen die ganzen in der PLO vereinigten Gruppen waren,
sondern bei der Hamas handelt es sich halt einfach um eine islamistische,
islamische Widerstandsbewegung, wie es offiziell ja heißt.
Also was Hamas heißt, also immer Hamas heißt auf Arabisch Islamische Widerstandsbewegung.
Man kann aber auch sagen, dass es sich um Islamisten handelt.
Sie sind ja so aus der Muslimbruderschaft aus Ägypten.
Vorgegangen, die noch eine viel längere Geschichte hat. Also die Hamas war auf
jeden Fall anders als die PLO und hat das auch gleich klar gemacht.
Das heißt, seit 2006 herrscht im Gazastreifen die Hamas und seitdem gibt's Ärger.
Ja, und was aber auch noch als weitere Komplikation ist, dass die Muslimbrüderschaft
der auch zwischenzeitlich in Ägypten an die Macht gekommen war,
aber dann vom Militär weggeputscht wurde.
Das heißt, auch ist jetzt nicht so,
dass jetzt die ägyptische Regierung jetzt die Muslimbrüderschaft unterstützen
würde und quasi über die Muslimbrüderschaft jetzt da versucht was zu tun,
sondern auch die haben ja Probleme mit der Muslimbruderschaft,
weswegen die auch die Hamas-Leute nicht in Ägypten haben,
wollen wir jetzt die Frage, warum jetzt wegen Vertreibung und warum gehen die
nicht nach Ägypten rüber, sondern die Hamas-Kämpfer sind auch in Ägypten nicht willkommen.
Ja, also vielleicht kann man an der Stelle mal einen Strich ziehen.
Also es gibt natürlich jetzt noch tausend geschichtliche Details,
die man jetzt hier aufzählen könnte.
Aber ich sag mal, im Groben haben wir jetzt insbesondere die militärischen,
politisch-militärischen Konflikte, die sozusagen dieses letzte Jahrhundert dominiert haben,
aufgezählt, an denen sich die nennenswerten Änderungen der Gebietsbesetzung
und der Verschiebung der Machtverhältnisse letztlich festmachen lassen.
Und insgesamt bleibt aber der ganze Nahosten eben ein, wie man sagt immer so
schön, ein Pulverfass, weil halt einfach immer kleinste Vorkommnisse können
eben zur weiteren Destabilisierung führen.
Da ist natürlich jetzt der arabische Frühling zu nennen, der hast du ja im Prinzip
schon angedeutet, das war ja dann sozusagen die Auswirkung in Ägypten,
dass dort halt der Präsident gestürzt wurde.
Dann gab es Wahlen, Muslimbruderschaft kam ran und dann haben halt irgendwann
das Militär gesagt, so ja, nee, machen wir nicht.
Ja, wir haben gesehen, was der Syrienkonflikt für ein Leid ausgelöst hat und
auch das Aufflammen des IS, des Islamischen Staates.
Die Kriege im Irak, auch Nachgang zu 9-11 spielen natürlich auch nochmal alle eine besondere Rolle.
Und vor allem ist halt das Thema Palästina zu so einem Globalthema geworden
und ist eigentlich auch immer das,
woran sich alles festmachen lässt bei dieser schwierigen Annäherung zwischen
dem arabischen und dem westlichen Raum vor allem.
Der Eindruck, der bei mir jetzt auch entstanden ist,
aus all dem, was passiert ist,
historisch ist, dass im Grunde genommen die Palästinenser,
wobei man korrekterweise von arabischen Palästinensern sprechen müsste,
weil auch die Juden und die Christen,
die da leben, sind auch alle Palästinenser, dass die im Wesentlichen instrumentalisiert
worden sind von allen möglichen arabischen Ländern,
um diesen Konflikt mit Israel zu schüren.
Schüren. Das heißt, dass im Grunde genommen auch der Konflikt in Palästina so
ein bisschen ein Stellvertreterkrieg oder ein Stellvertreterkonflikt ist zwischen
Israel und dem Großteil der arabischen Staaten.
Was jetzt gerade auch wichtig ist im Zuge der sogenannten Normalisierungsbemühungen,
die Israel jetzt unternommen hat, nämlich die Verhältnisse mit mehr arabischen
Staaten zu normalisieren.
Die meisten arabischen Länder haben nicht mal diplomatische Kontakte zu Israel
und erkennen Israel als Staat gar nicht an.
Da hat jetzt in den letzten Jahren Israel zunehmend Fortschritte gemacht.
Und es sieht so aus, wird jetzt vom Ausgang des Konflikts abhängen, dass aber eine große
Zahl von Normalisierungen passieren wird und dass dann im Zuge dessen quasi
die Palästinenser überflüssig werden als Instrument dieses Konflikts.
Was auch für diese These spricht, aus meiner Sicht,
dass es den arabischen Ländern mehr um sich selbst,
um ihre eigenen Interessen geht, als um die Interessen der arabischen Palästinenser
ist, dass, ja, vorhin erwähnt, der Gaza-Streifen unter ägyptischer Verwaltung lange stand.
Die Westbank unter jordanischer Verwaltung und in der Zeit ging es den Palästinensern,
den Arabischen jetzt auch nicht gut.
Ja, also es war jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie gesagt hätten, hier super,
ja, also auch die haben da jetzt nicht,
nicht jetzt das, aus meiner Sicht,
das Wohl der Palästinenser irgendwie jetzt gerade als,
als hohe Priorität gehabt, sondern eben hatten den Eindruck,
dass man sagen diesen Konflikt einfach hervorragend nehmen und instrumentalisieren
kann, um Israel unter Druck zu setzen.
Ja und ich meine so Länder wie Saudi-Arabien und so weiter, denen hätte es ja
auch nie an Mitteln gefehlt sozusagen hier einfach mal für wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung zu sorgen in diesen Gebieten.
Das findet ja auch nicht statt. Warum das dann im Einzelnen nicht stattfindet,
das lässt sich nicht mit abschließender Sicherheit,
nicht mal mit annähernder Sicherheit in irgendeiner Form sagen,
weil wir haben es ja hier mit einem Machtspiel zu tun, was auch deutlich über
dieses Gebiet hinaus geht.
Das hat was mit dem Verhältnis Saudi-Arabiens zum Iran zu tun.
Das hat was mit den Konflikten, die Iran auch mit dem Irak hat. Es gab ja viele Kriege.
Syrien ist hier ein Player, der eigene Interessen verfolgt.
Und neben Israel und palästinensischen Gebieten,
gibt es ja auch noch andere Länder, die genauso auch quasi unter diesem Konflikt leiden.
Da ist vor allem der nördliche Nachbar der Libanon zu nennen,
der sozusagen auch so ein mehr Religionsstaat geworden ist.
Aber nicht nur das, auch so ein Staat in dem mehrere oder fast gar keine Mächte mehr,
je nachdem man es betrachten möchte, wirken, weil auf der einen Seite hast du
halt eine fortwährende korrupte Regierung und Libanon liegt wirtschaftlich mittlerweile
am Boden und im Süden hast du dann eben wiederum die Hezbollah als Staat im Staate,
die eben auch eine weitere Gefährdung, gestützt durch den Iran,
für Israel im Norden darstellt.
Also man kann hier immer wieder schauen auf die einzelnen Player und die sind sich alle nicht einig.
So dieses einheitliche, jetzt muss es aber mal für die arabische Bevölkerung
in Palästina einen Start geben und wir setzen das jetzt mal durch.
Die Möglichkeit hätte es gegeben, wenn sich da auch wirklich alle einig gewesen wären.
Und ich meine im Moment so ein Statement jetzt auch zum Thema jetzt,
okay Hizbollah greifen die jetzt auch aus dem Norden an, die sind deutlich potenter
als Hamas, also besser bewaffnet zahlenmäßig, viel stärker, wie gesagt,
vor allem vom, auch ja, Iran.
Unterstützt und da ist es so, dass jetzt die offizielle libanesische Regierung
eigentlich nichts dagegen hätte,
wenn Hisbollah Israel angreift,
aber nicht weil sie etwas gegen Israel haben,
sondern weil sie es sehr willkommen heißen würden, wenn Israel Hisbollah dezimieren
würde und sie dann, sagen wir, Hezbollah loswerden auf diese Art und Weise.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das so einfach zu beantworten ist. Es gab ja 2006,
also schon vor 17 Jahren, gab es ja schon mal diesen israelischen Hezbollah-Krieg,
wo Israel ja auch im Libanon einmarschiert ist, aber sich dann halt auch wieder zurückziehen musste.
Das war für alle Beteiligten kein Spaß. Die Hezbollah ist dann zwar auch dezimiert
worden, aber genauso auch die israelische Armee.
Da sind sehr viele Israelis ums Leben gekommen. Und am Ende hat es dann doch
dazu geführt, dass die Hezbollah nach wie vor existiert und weiterhin vom Iran aufgerüstet wurde.
Ich meine, ich habe das jetzt auch nur erwähnt, um einmal klar zu sein,
dass man nicht jetzt einfach nur zwischen, ja,
auf der einen Seite die Israelis und auf der anderen Seite die arabischen Nachbarn,
sondern da gibt es eben auch sehr unterschiedliche Interessen und natürlich
auch so ein bisschen der,
ich sag mal, Saudi-Arabien und Iran sind jetzt natürlich vor allem auch im Blickpunkt
jetzt als Akteure und deren Konflikt wiederum,
weil die ja unterschiedliche Zweige des Islam repräsentieren und vermutlich
auch die militärisch stärksten Mächte in der Gegend sind und dort natürlich
jetzt auch beide fleißig mitmischen.
Und was wir jetzt auch größtenteils ausgelassen haben, war, dass viel von diesen
Kriegen auch im Kalten Krieg stattfand.
Das heißt, da haben sich dann auch wiederum US-Interessen oder NATO-Interessen
und sowjetische Interessen dort sind dort auch aufeinander getroffen und haben
das Ganze teilweise zusätzlich befeuert,
teilweise aber auch durchaus stabilisierend eingewirkt, die Großmächte dort.
Das wäre mein Eindruck, also.
Also ich denke, das wird ja nicht unsere letzte Sendung zu diesem Thema bleiben.
Und wir können sicherlich auch noch auf einzelne Player noch mal separat schauen.
Gerade das Involvement von Russland wird ja hier auch noch mal kräftig hinterfragt,
ja, inwiefern die hier weiteres Öl ins Feuer gießen.
Ebola, Iran etc. Also all diese ganzen Kräfte müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch
nochmal aufzählen, aber das würde jetzt...
Zu weit führen. An dieser Stelle denke ich sollten wir mal auf die aktuelle
Situation zu sprechen kommen. Was ist also passiert?
Vor einer Woche am 7.
Oktober 2023 gab es halt einen Überraschungsangriff der Hamas auf Israel.
Und um vielleicht zu verstehen was da passiert ist, muss man auch erstmal die
aktuelle Situation von diesem Gaza-Streifen vielleicht nochmal klar rücken.
Der Gaza-Streifen ist halt im südlichsten Teil Israels am Mittelmeer gelegen
und ist gar nicht mal so groß. Also von der Länge her ist das so ein bisschen
wie London, kann man sagen.
Also von Norden bis Süden sind es gerade mal 40 Kilometer.
An der breitesten Stelle sind es zwölf Kilometer, an der schmalsten Stelle dieses
Streifens sind es irgendwie fünf oder sechs Kilometer. Also es ist wirklich
ein sehr kleines Gebiet und dort leben halt zwei Millionen Leute.
Und da es halt jetzt schon in den letzten Jahren so viel Ärger gab mit der Hamas,
weil Raketenangriffe, wie sie jetzt stattgefunden haben, sind nichts Neues.
Sozusagen etwas, was einerseits ja am Norden von der Hespola auch schon immer
wieder betrieben wurde, aber eben auch von der Hamas seit 2006 regelmäßig stattfindet.
Deswegen gibt es hier einen Sicherheitsstreifen um dieses ganze Gebiet herum und einen Zaun.
Teilweise auch Mauern, teilweise auch bis tief in den Boden gerammte Befestigungen,
um die Tunnelbildung zu verhindern.
Das hat nur so begrenzt funktioniert, kann man glaube ich sagen.
Und in diesem Gebiet, in dem es sozusagen rundherum um Gaza eigentlich nur Israel gibt,
mit der einzigen Ausnahme der Südlinie, wo es halt an Ägypten grenzt,
In diesem Gebiet ist die Hamas halt seit Jahren dabei,
im Prinzip die Voraussetzung für weitere Angriffe auf Israel zu schaffen,
indem sie Tunnel baut, indem sie Waffenlager anlegt, unterirdisch,
teilweise in zivilen Gebäuden oder vielleicht sogar mehrheitlich, ich weiß es nicht.
Und ja, eine permanente Bedrohung Israels darstellen.
Und Israel hat sich dann entsprechend gewappnet, vor allem durch Technologie kann man sagen.
Also erstmal durch klassische Militärtechnik, also eben diese ganzen abschottenden
Zäune und Anlagen, entsprechende Militärposten um Gaza rundherum.
Es gibt da keinen Ort, der nicht in irgendeiner Form eine militärische Präsenz hat normalerweise.
Ja, und vor allem in den letzten Jahren haben sie dort technisch aufgerüstet
und zumindest Haben Sie das geglaubt, indem Sie dort automatische Überwachungsanlagen
installiert haben mit Sensoriken, mit Kameras und allem Möglichen?
Ja, also die Fertigstellung von diesem Zaun oder Mauer, wie immer man das Ganze
nennen will, wurde so Ende 2021 verkündet.
Also am 7. Dezember 2021 hat Israel angekündigt, dass diese Grenzbefestigungen
jetzt fertiggestellt sind.
Vor allem der unterirdische Teil und ja, wie du schon richtig sagtest,
so ziemlich viel Hightech, also oben einen Zaun.
Befestigungen, die tief nach unten gehen. Wie tief ist geheim,
aber so wohl teilweise bis zu 30 Meter nach unten,
um zu verhindern, dass dort Tunnel gebaut werden, mit entsprechenden Sensoren,
die dann tief eingelassen sind, sodass es Alarm gibt, wenn da versucht jemand
drunter durchzutunneln.
Und dann eine Seebarriere, weil auf der Mittelmeerseite dann eben jede Menge
Radarsysteme und Kontroll- und Überwachungsräume plus ferngesteuerte Maschinengewehre,
so ein bisschen wie,
ja, an Star Wars erinnerte mich das dann,
wo sie immer diese Century Auto Cannons haben,
die sie dann irgendwo reinstellen oder es ist generell so ein Science Fiction
Trope, habe ich das Gefühl, wo dann, ja, wie diese automatischen,
ganz in Aliens hatten, gab es die Dinger auch und so.
Also solche Sachen haben die da, wobei die, glaube ich, nicht intelligent sind,
wobei angeblich KI haben sie wohl auch eingesetzt dort.
Und ja, das Ding war halt, wie gesagt, ist jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren fertig.
Insgesamt 65 Kilometer, 140.000 Tonnen Stahl und hat wohl dreieinhalb Jahre
Bauzeit gehabt, so das Ganze. Aber ja...
Ganz offensichtlich hat es nicht gereicht bzw.
War vielleicht auch mit eine Ursache, dass das Ganze passieren konnte,
weil ja, man doch dann sehr auf Technik vertraut hat und ein Gefühl,
dass Menschen einfach, wenn die, also kaum etwas ist so gut wie Menschen,
wenn es darum geht, irgendwie Technik zu zerstören, die nicht von Menschen bewacht ist.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, Roboter aufstehen, also Roboter haben einfach keine Chance,
so, no way, also Menschen sind einfach zu bösartig und was halt hier in dem
Fall eben auch passiert ist, also es ging wohl los, Du dachtest,
mit einer Raketenbarrage, mit mehreren tausend Raketen,
die in kurzer Zeit abgeschossen wurden, die ja auf Israel, die dann den Iron
Dome überlastet haben, sodass viele der Raketen dann auch durchgekommen sind.
Also Iron Dome muss man dazu sagen ist das Flugabwehrsystem oder Raketenabwehrsystem
der Israelis, was in den letzten Jahren ausgebaut haben.
Was halt mit Abstand als das beste Abwehrsystem gilt, weil es halt auch in der
Lage ist mit sehr kurzer Warnmeldung einen Angriff zu verhindern.
Die israelischen Siedlungen sind ja teilweise nur wenige Kilometer vom Gaza-Streifen entfernt.
Ashkolon und so weiter. Also da fliegt so eine Rakete nur wenige Sekunden,
bis klar ist, wohin es geht.
Und das System ist halt in der Lage, glaube ich, nach zwölf Sekunden oder so
was, dann schon entsprechend zu reagieren, eine Abschussrakete loszuschicken,
die dann halt die andere Rakete im Anflug zerstören kann.
Wobei, ja, also das war der Luftangriff, aber auf den Zaun gab es wohl auch
dann einen Cyberangriff oder mehrere Cyberangriffe,
bei denen halt wohl die Kontrollzentren auch teilweise einfach plötzlich offline waren,
was dann begleitet wurde auch durch Drohnenangriffe auf bestimmte Installationen am Zaun,
unter anderem eben diese automatischen Kameras, die wurden dann eben wie wir
das auch aus der Ukraine kennen.
Dann mit handelsüblichen Drohnen mit Granaten unten dran,
dann die wurden einfach von oben abgeworfen und ja schon waren halt diese Geschütze
auch außer Gefecht und das führte dann insgesamt dazu,
dass wohl ja die Israelis größtenteils dann ja taub und blind waren für die
Dinge, die da am Zaun vor sich gehen.
Und am Zaun wurde, der wurde dann wohl an rund zehn verschiedenen Stellen gleichzeitig durchbrochen,
teilweise gesprengt, teilweise mit Bulldozern entfernt und ja,
plus scheint es ihnen auch gelungen zu sein auf See mit kleinen Booten rüber zu kommen.
Auch trotz der Seebarriere, die zu umgehen und dann auch noch James Bond mäßig
mit so motorisierten Paraglidern auch noch aus der Luft dann anzugreifen. A.
Motorisiert, also so Ultraleichtflugzeuge im Prinzip?
B. Ja, also Paraglider, sozusagen schon so ein Fallschirm,
aber mit so einem Dreirad unten dran, mit einem Propeller hinten dran,
von dem du auch sagen, mit dem kannst du vom Boden starten und dann also motorisiert
eben Paraglider nennen sich die Dinger, glaube ich.
Also man nennt die ultraleicht Flugzeug, aber egal. Hängegleiter,
das ist so eine stabile Geschichte und wenn es Fallschirme waren,
dann sind es wie Paragleiter.
Egal, auf jeden Fall mit minimaler Technik effektiv über den Zaun.
Und dann mit Motorrädern und Pickup Trucks oder wie wir das auch kennen,
teilweise mit Maschinengewehren hinten auf die Ladefläche montiert auf Lafetten
und so sind dann eben mehrere,
In der Gegend von 3000 kann man von ausgehend,
genaue Zahlen weiß man nicht, aber so größenordnungsmäßig dann auf israelisches
Gelände vorgedrungen und dann an manchen Stellen dann bis zu 30 Kilometer ungefähr
ins Land rein an einigen wenigen Stellen.
Und haben dann dort ziemlich gewütet.
BK'IN DR. MERKEL Vor allem haben sie erst einmal Militärposten überrannt.
Das ist ja schon mal ganz unfassbar gewesen.
Also es wurden diverse Militärposten der Israelis, die sich unmittelbar am Zaun
oder in den nächsten Siedlungen befanden, übernommen.
Also einfach geradet. Man muss sagen, der Angriff war morgens um 6.30 Uhr oder
so. Sie haben das genau so abgepasst, dass es zum Schichtwechsel stattfand.
Dazu war ja dann auch noch den Tag vorher Jom Kippur, also der Festtag,
der dem Konflikt vor 50 Jahren, also dem Krieg vor 50 Jahren schon den Namen gegeben hat.
Und im Prinzip am Schabbat läuft ja sozusagen in Israel sowieso immer etwas
weniger. Das ist ja so ein spezieller Tag. Und dementsprechend,
sich eben viele dieser Militärposten nicht entsprechend gerüstet und vorbereitet
oder auch nur gewarnt und wurden halt überrannt. Viele Soldaten kamen dabei
schon ums Leben, dann wurden auch entsprechend Gerät entwendet.
Also die fuhren dann halt mit israelischen gepanzerten Fahrzeugen durch die
Gegend und im Prinzip stieß also jetzt eine riesige Terrorbande zahlreich in
alle Richtungen von Gaza auf die nächstgelegenen Orte zu.
Und man konnte in den Bildern auch mindestens zwei verschiedene Arten von Truppen
beobachten, die da rein sind.
Das eine waren halt Kämpfer, die
im wesentlichen Waffen und Munition dabei hatten, aber ansonsten nichts.
Also keine Plate Carrier,
also keine Panzerung, also keine Körperpanzerung oder so,
die sie jetzt vor Kugeln geschützt hätte, keine Verbandskästen,
keine Medizin, keine Tourniquets, kein Wasser, ja.
Also wo man dann davon ausgehen könnte, also entweder wollten sie gar nicht
weit rein oder was wahrscheinlicher ist, dass viele von denen nicht damit gerechnet
haben, wieder zurückzukommen.
Das heißt, dass es auch einen Großteil von Kämpfern waren, die letztlich das
Ganze als Selbstmordangriff gesehen haben.
Die da rein sind, ohne Wasser, ohne Medikamente und dann eben auf alles geschossen haben,
was sich an Israelis bewegt hat und gezielt versucht haben,
so viele Israelis wie möglich zu töten,
darunter dann auch Frauen und Kinder und Alte und Behinderte und ja,
also ja, dort im Prinzip gewütet haben, wie Eis ist, da kommen wir dann auch noch später drauf.
Bis dann gab es eine Gruppe, konnte man sehen,
die waren, die schienen militärisch professioneller ausgerüstet zu sein,
die hatten halt dann teilweise eben auch Körperpanzerung und so mehr militärisches
Gier und viele von denen hatten wohl den Auftrag,
Gefangene zu nehmen, also Geiseln zu nehmen.
Das waren dann im Wesentlichen...
Die dann diese 100 oder 100 bis zu 150 Geisen, ich glaube 120 sind bestätigt
im Moment, die halt mit zurückzuschleppen.
Und es gab dann auch Meldungen von den Gefangenen Palästinensern,
dass die zum einen selber überrascht waren, wie erfolgreich sie waren,
also wie weit sie gekommen sind und damit hatten sie nicht gerechnet.
Und die ganze Sache war wohl auch sehr kompartmentalisiert, also sie wussten
selber nicht, dass es so ein großes Ding werden würde.
Sie wussten nur jeweils, was ihr kleiner Trupp für eine Aufgabe hatte und haben
auch erst kurzfristig nur das mitgeteilt bekommen, dass sie jetzt da raus sollen.
Also das Ganze war eben auch sehr aufwendig geplant, mit natürlich sehr viel
auch durchaus Sicherheit im Hintergrund.
Sowieso viele Zellen, die unabhängige Zellen, die voneinander nichts wissen
und die dann losgezogen sind.
Und man geht davon aus, dass die Vorbereitung wohl mindestens sechs Monate gedauert
haben muss von dieser komplexen Operation und dass das wahrscheinlich sogar
mit Vorlauf irgendwann bis zu zwei Jahre zurückreicht,
die Vorbereitung dieser Operation.
Das heißt.
Wenn man jetzt überlegt, wer da vielleicht seine Finger drin hat in dieser konkreten Aktion jetzt,
dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch Russland so ein bisschen abhaken,
weil wahrscheinlich in der Zeit sie einfach andere Sorgen hatten.
Und wie viel jetzt Iran konkret davon wusste, dass das passieren wird,
ist auch noch umschlagen.
Und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass auch einige, also speziell im Iran,
jetzt auch ein bisschen erschrocken sind über die, ich sag mal,
großen in Anführungszeichen Erfolge.
Und ja, dass das bisschen aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist, das Ganze auch möglicherweise.
Gehen wir doch erstmal noch ein bisschen drauf ein, was sozusagen noch passiert
ist, ohne jetzt hier zu viel in die schrecklichen Details zu gehen.
Ich denke, was alle noch mitbekommen haben, ist halt auch der Angriff auf dieses Technofestival,
wo halt in dem Moment, wo die Kunde kamen, dass da ein Angriff stattfindet,
alle fliehen wollten, zu den Autos gefahren sind und dort eben schon die Terroristen
warteten und alle erschossen haben.
Hunderte gestorben, 260 war die letzte Zahl, die ich gehört habe.
Viele sind von dort auch entführt worden.
Andere Gräueltaten, die stattgefunden haben. Ich will das hier auch alles gar
nicht weiter wiederholen. Das habt ihr ja auch sicherlich mitbekommen.
Und die Reaktion der israelischen Armee war irgendwann dann auch da.
Also nicht rechtzeitig, nicht früh genug, also schon gar nicht im Vorfeld.
Dann eben überrascht worden und dann hat es auch teilweise Stunden gedauert
bis wirklich in alle angegriffenen Bereiche überhaupt erstmal die Armee vorgerückt
war und dann hat es auch noch teilweise Tage gedauert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt schon davon sprechen kann, dass wirklich alle Nester
ausgehoben sind, aber es hat teilweise Tage gedauert, auch noch die Angreifer
aus den letzten Orten zu vertreiben und wegzukämpfen.
Und es sollen wohl so um die tausend Angreifer auf israelischem Gebiet getötet worden sein.
Also insofern ja, ein auch ja sehr,
sehr blutiges Ergebnis, wobei Israel ungefähr,
man klingt jetzt ein bisschen zynisch, aber normalerweise so,
ja, von irgendwie einem Faktor von 10 zu 1 mindestens ausgeht.
Also, dass das sozusagen, dass sie das anstreben, dass, sagen,
mindestens 10 Gegner getötet werden für einen getöteten Israeli.
Das war jedenfalls auch in vergangenen Konflikten oft das Verhältnis von Opfern
auf Opferzahlen auf beiden Seiten.
Und diesmal war es wohl so ungefähr ein 1 zu 1 und das ist natürlich ein riesen Schock
für Israel, weswegen ich dann auch davon ausgehe, dass sie jetzt versuchen werden
wieder ihr übliches Verhältnis an Opfern herzustellen,
leider, um zu sagen, ja, aus Prinzip, Abspeckung.
Keine Ahnung, also ich glaube nicht, dass es hier primär um Zahlen geht,
sondern man muss sich jetzt einfach
mal vorstellen, dass sozusagen diese Situation für Israel ist halt.
Das Schlimmste, was dem Land widerfahren konnte, in ihrer Selbstgewissheit.
Das haben wir ja bei den anderen Konflikten und beim ersten Jom Kippur-Krieg auch schon erwähnt.
Man wähnte sich halt sicher. Man wähnte sich sicher durch eine hochgerüstete Armee.
Man wähnte sich sicher durch eine maximale Absperrung dieses Gebiets,
durch den Eierndom, die Geheimdienstaufklärung, die traditionell sehr hoch angesehen ist.
Man geht immer davon aus, dass der israelische Geheimdienst alles weiß und dass
es unmöglich ist, dass so eine große Operation geplant werden kann,
ohne dass man davon Wind bekommen hat.
Jetzt wissen wir nicht, ob nicht doch jemand Wind davon bekommen hat und das
sozusagen nur auf dem Weg nach oben ignoriert wurde. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber so oder so, im Endeffekt war einfach die entsprechende militärische Reaktion
zu spät und hat eben dazu geführt,
dass mindestens zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt mindestens 1300 Israelis umgebracht worden sind.
Nochmal wahrscheinlich das Dreifache davon an Verletzten zu beklagen ist und
es dabei eben einfach All Walks of Life betroffen hat. Also es hat einfach wirklich
auch die Schutzlosesten hier auf grausamste Art und Weise niedergemetzelt worden.
Und das ist dann halt schon so ein 9-11-Moment.
Und wenn man es mal auf die Bevölkerungsdichte umrechnet, was sozusagen bei
9-11 passiert ist, sind auch 3.000 Leute umgekommen.
Hier sind wir quasi bei der Hälfte dieser Zahl, aber bei einer viel,
viel kleineren Gesellschaft.
Also das ist sozusagen aus der Perspektive Israels ist das so 9-11 mal 15.
Es ist einfach eine super Tragödie und das trifft natürlich das Land auf vielen Ebenen super hart.
Abgesehen davon, dass natürlich einfach der Act selber schon überhaupt nicht geht.
Es ist halt einfach ein Schockzustand, in dem sich diese Gesellschaft jetzt
befindet und die kennt natürlich jetzt nur eine Reaktion und die ist,
wir halten da jetzt so lange drauf, bis da nichts mehr kommt.
So, das ist einfach die einzige denkbare Reaktion.
Und natürlich zittert jetzt so ein bisschen die Welt mit, weil sie auf der einen
Seite das Verteidigungsrecht Israels natürlich anerkennt,
aber auch weiß, was, und das haben wir ja hier vorfeldausführlich und auch deshalb
ausführlich besprochen, weil das alles so eine unglaubliche weitlaufende Dimension hat.
Denn wenn es hier richtig knallt und sich die Gemüter weltweit weiter aufheizen
um diesen Konflikt herum und das wird zwangsläufig passieren,
dann wissen wir halt nicht, welche Player hier noch mit reingehen.
Aber bevor wir auf dieses Zukunftsszenario gehen, wollte ich erstmal schauen,
was wir denken, was jetzt als Reaktion Israels passieren wird und was das alleine
jetzt erstmal bedeutet.
Also wir haben jetzt die letzte Woche gesehen, wie vor allem erstmal versucht hat,
klar Schiff zu kriegen, also erstmal die ganzen Kampfnester zu beenden und den
Angriff als solchen erstmal zurückzuschlagen und sozusagen die Angreifer wieder
auf das Gebiet von Gaza zurückzudrängen.
Da gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus, dass es jetzt nach einer Woche weitgehend passiert.
Parallel dazu gibt es natürlich nach wie vor Raketenangriffe.
Es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt nur am ersten Tag mal ein paar Raketen geregnet
hat, sondern Sie sind mit einer Barrage von, ich weiß nicht,
ich habe alle Zahlen gehört, von 2.000 bis 5.000 Raketen gestartet.
Das sind günstige Raketen, die alle möglichen Reichweiten haben,
die also sehr kurze Flugstrecken absolvieren können, aber auch teilweise bis zu 150 Kilometer.
Man geht davon aus, dass sie im Prinzip alle Bereiche Israels erreichen können.
Dieser Eierndom ist permanent in Betrieb und andere Flugabwehrsysteme sind ja
nicht das einzige System, was es da gibt. Es gibt auch noch diese Sling of David
Abwehrsysteme etc. Egal, das ist ein technisches Detail.
Aber das läuft sozusagen noch, also jetzt schon.
Obwohl Israel Luftschläge gegen Gaza fliegt am laufenden Meter und da jetzt
glaube ich auch schon irgendwie 6000 Angriffe geflogen worden sind,
gibt es nach wie vor Angriffe mit Raketen auf israelisches Gebiet.
Und konkret, man fragt sich dann natürlich immer, wo kommen diese Raketen eigentlich her,
wie schaffen die das jetzt tausende von Raketen abzuschießen in kurzer Zeit
und die haben sich ihre eigenen kleinen Mehrfachraketenwerfer gebaut,
so im Prinzip brauchst du ja nicht viel mehr als einen Rohr oder als einen Haufen
Rohre, die sind dann in einem Rahmen entsprechend angeordnet,
passen hinten auf einen Pickup-Truck.
Da gehen dann so 20, 30 Raketen ungefähr, passen da rein. Die sind dann entsprechend
verkabelt und ja, die haben dann quasi ihre Mini-Stalinorgeln im Grunde genommen.
Das zeigt auch so ein bisschen die Problematik, man fragt sich natürlich mal gut,
wie kommen denn jetzt die so Waffen da rein,
warum schafft Israel das nicht, das zu unterbinden und am Beispiel dieser Raketenwerfer,
ich meine, du hast eine Stadt mit zwei Millionen und die will halt versorgt
werden und unter anderem brauchst du auch.
Weiß nicht, Wasserleitungen um Wasser zu transportieren oder zersägt werden,
um einen Mehrfachraketenwerfer oder ja, selber die Hülle von Raketen daraus zu fertigen.
Deswegen, das ist so ein bisschen die die Problematik. Und ja,
bei der Frage, wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Also wir sollten erstmal noch beschreiben, was schon passiert ist.
Also was ja auch noch passiert ist, ist die Mobilisierung der Reservisten.
Israel hat eine Standing Army von ungefähr 160.000,
Soldaten, die permanent im Einsatz sind. Und man muss wissen,
jeder Israeli war bei der Armee.
Also sicherlich gibt es ein paar Ausnahmen, aber im Kern jeder Mann,
jede Frau in Israel war bei der IDF und das Reservistenherr ist dementsprechend sehr, sehr, sehr groß.
Ungefähr 300.000 Israelis aus der Reserve mobilisiert.
Das heißt, wir reden davon, dass wir jetzt quasi eine Armee von 460.000 Menschen.
Staat haben, auf einem Gebiet von der Größe von Hessen und die jetzt in irgendeiner
Form bereit sind, das Land zu verteidigen bzw.
Natürlich dann auch Gaza anzugreifen. Weil darauf läuft es jetzt hinaus.
Wenn man sich die öffentlichen Äußerungen des Ministerpräsidenten und der IDF-Vertreter
und Pressesprecher anschaut,
ist es klar, das offiziell formulierte Ziel Ziel ist, Hamas sozusagen so weit
zu zerstören, bis von ihnen keine Gefahr mehr ausgehen kann.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie sehr Hamas sich eben im Gaza-Streifen eingegraben hat,
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, dann ist halt klar,
dass das eben nur, also dass es nicht mal nur mit den jetzt schon laufenden
Luftschlägen getan ist,
sondern dass wir jetzt hier über eine Invasion reden, also einen direkten Einmarsch
der israelischen Armee auf den Gaza-Streifen ist speziell in Gaza,
der Stadt, also wenn man sich Gaza-Streifen anschaut, ist Norden die größte
Bevölkerungsdichte, eben in der Stadt Gaza, die dem Ganzen ihren Namen gegeben hat.
Nach Süden gibt es dann auch noch weitere Städte, die nicht ganz so groß sind.
Es gibt dann so eine Trennlinie, so ein, wie heißt der, der Wadi Gaza,
Gaza-Fluss, der halt den Norden und den Süden so auf zwei Drittel trennt.
Und die israelische Armee verteilt jetzt Nachrichten über alle Kanäle,
einschließlich Flugblättern, die über dem Gebiet verteilt werden,
wo halt die Bevölkerung in Gaza aufgefordert wird, sich doch südlich dieses
Gebietes zu begeben. Das betrifft ungefähr eine Million Menschen.
Sicherlich wird es nicht allen möglich sein, das auch zu tun,
zumal es auch Berichte gibt von Hamas-Kontrollposten, die die Leute auch teilweise
schon daran hindern oder ihnen zumindest zureden, das nicht zu tun.
Das muss man jetzt sehen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine große Fluchtbewegung und
wir stehen halt unter Umständen vor einem Einmarsch der israelischen Armee in Gaza,
was natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension hat.
Also das ist sozusagen das, was sich jetzt abzeichnet und wir stehen jetzt sozusagen
genau an diesem Punkt und werden wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo wir diesen Podcast schon veröffentlicht haben, werden wir unter Umständen
auch schon die ersten Einmarschbewegungen dokumentiert bekommen.
Jetzt, wo wir jetzt gerade reden, ist es gerade noch nicht so weit.
Was auch noch erwähnenswert ist, du sagtest ja vorhin 450.000,
Soldaten, die mobilisiert sind.
Auf Deutschland umgerechnet ungefähr wäre das so, als wenn Deutschland jetzt
vier Millionen Soldaten unter Waffen gebracht hätte.
Nur mal so also die die Relationen und was vielleicht auch noch interessant
ist jetzt der der Vergleich Israel-Gaza also Israel hat so mit 55.000 Dollar pro.
An Bruttoinlandsprodukt ungefähr dasselbe pro Kopf wie Deutschland.
Also Deutschland auch so 54, 55.
Also du kannst sagen, Israel ist pro Kopf ein ähnlich reiches Land wie Deutschland.
Gaza gehört dagegen zu den ärmsten Regionen der Welt mit ungefähr,
ich weiß nicht, zwischen 1000 und 1500 Dollar.
Pro Kopf Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Das heißt, wir haben also jetzt ein Israel, was wirtschaftlich ja ungefähr 30
Mal so viel Geld pro Kopf zur Verfügung hat.
Und auch nochmal, ich glaube die sind bei 3,5-4% vom GDP, was sie für Verteidigung ausgeben.
Also Israel ja, hat ein substanzielles Militär und ein sehr modernes Militär.
Israel hat auch die F-35 und als einziges Land dort in der Gegend,
also nicht mal die Saudis, haben glaube ich jetzt bisher welche bekommen.
Kriegen wir vielleicht auch keine wegen Israel oder erst welche,
wenn sie Frieden mit Israel machen.
Und ansonsten, ja, einfach, ich glaube, sie über tausend Kampfpanzer und auch
tausende von gepanzerten Kampfpanzerwagen und wahrscheinlich auch eine Luftwaffe
mit irgendwie in der Größenordnung von tausend Flugzeugen.
Also das ist schon militärisch von der Modernität her und von der Ausbildung
und von der Zahl her ist das jetzt kein Vergleich.
Wenn man jetzt auf der einen Seite eben das israelische Militär,
auf der anderen Seite Hamas mit 30.000,
Kämpfern und improvisierten Gerät, ist das Kräfteverhältnis erst einmal unglaublich
einseitig auf Seiten Israels, so rein militärisch betrachtet.
Tja, nur wir wissen halt, wenn man angreift, dann ist die Situation der Verteidiger
definitiv erstmal im Vorteil.
Und außerdem haben wir es hier mit einer Organisation zu tun,
die mal salopp gesagt auf ihre Bevölkerung weitgehend scheißt.
Würde sie das nicht tun, hätten sie diese Angriffe niemals gestartet.
Denn bei den Dimensionen, die sie dort geplant haben, muss der Hamas klar gewesen
sein, was die Folge davon sein wird.
Und die werden jetzt nicht überrascht sein, dass Israel jetzt auf ihr Gelinde
kommen will und sagen, hola, so haben wir aber nicht gerechnet,
wegen der paar Raketen, regt ihr euch gleich so auf, regt euch mal ab.
Sondern das ist Teil der Kalkulation. Es geht darum.
Es war das Ziel von Anfang an, hier eine maximale Eskalation zu erreichen.
Ob es in der Dimension am Ende so von ihnen vorhergesagt wurde,
das werden wir vielleicht nie erfahren, spielt zu diesem Zeitpunkt natürlich
auch gar keine Rolle mehr, weil so wird es jetzt kommen.
Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass die Hamas sich eingraben wird und sie werden
halt, so wie sie es bisher schon immer getan haben, sich unter zivilen Gebäuden verstecken.
Sie werden sich in Krankenhäusern, allen möglichen anderen Orten,
strategisch wichtige Tunnel, Lagerstätten, Waffenlager und Rückzugsgebiete geschaffen haben.
Während Israel jetzt versucht, all die ihnen bekannten Funktionsräume erst mal
direkt von der Luft zu beschießen,
um dann später in einem zweiten Schritt durch die Bodenoffensive dann all der
Leute habhaft zu werden, der sie habhaft werden wollen.
Und da zeigt sich gleich noch das nächste Problem, abgesehen davon,
dass also schon in dem ersten Schritt der gerade läuft und im zweiten Schritt
der folgt, natürlich tausende der normalen zivilen Bevölkerung in Gaza zu Schaden
kommen werden und schon zu Schaden gekommen sind.
Wir haben ja auch noch das spezifische Problem der Geiseln.
Und das ist halt in Israel schon immer eine besonders sensitive Geschichte gewesen.
Es gab Fälle, da hat die Hamas zwei oder drei israelische Soldaten entführt bekommen.
Die sind dann gegen, ich weiß nicht, hunderte palästinensische Gefangene getauscht worden,
weil einfach die die israelische Bevölkerung bereit ist,
diesen hohen Preis zu zahlen, weil eben der Schutz des Einzelnen,
des Individuums in Israel, in dieser Bevölkerung so einen hohen Stellenwert hat.
Und der hat deshalb so einen hohen Stellenwert,
weil das ganze Selbstverständnis des Staates, dass das Grundgerüst Israels basiert
unter anderem darauf, dass es den starken Staat gibt.
Sicherheit für alle sicherzustellen.
Wir haben ja diese ganze Geschichte erzählt. Die Verfolgung,
die Vertreibung aus allen Ländern, Vertreibung aus Judäa, aber eben auch die
Vertreibung wiederum aus all den Gebieten, wo sie hingeflohen sind.
Das heißt, die Geschichte des Judentums ist geprägt von Verfolgung,
Vertreibung, von Bedrohung Und spätestens mit dem Holocaust hat das Ganze auch
eine Dimension angenommen,
wo Sicherheit und dieses Lass uns doch bitte in Ruhe so eine hohe Bedeutung
hat, dass das quasi so die Grundräson ist, dass einfach der Staat hat das zu leisten für die Bürger.
Das ist sozusagen Thema Nummer eins.
Und das ist halt jetzt durch diesen Angriff schon zu Schaden gekommen und bei
Entführung ist es natürlich auch so eine Sache,
dass jetzt auch die ganze Gesellschaft hier in so einen Grenzbereich reinkommt,
weil sie wissen auf der einen Seite, diese Geiseln zurückzubekommen ist fast
ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Hamas, weil sie das weiß, weil sie dieses
große Interesse an dem Zurückbringen von Geiseln der israelischen Gesellschaft
kennt, natürlich ihn maximal schwer machen wird, sozusagen.
Also wenn so eine Befreiung überhaupt möglich ist, dann eben nur unter größten Verlusten.
Und das schmerzt natürlich dann auch wieder auf der anderen Seite und wird natürlich
auch sehr viel mehr Kollateralschäden in der eigenen Bevölkerung,
also in der Gaza-Bevölkerung, nach sich ziehen. Also hier gibt es keine Gewinner.
Das wird einfach eine ganz furchtbare Geschichte werden.
Er hatte ja dieses Kräfteverhältnis hingewiesen
und deswegen ist Hamas halt in erster Linie eine Terrororganisation und Terror
oder Terrorismus ist nicht wirklich eine militärische Strategie,
sondern es ist eine Medienstrategie, um Bilder zu erzeugen.
Schon richtig sagtest, das Ziel von Hamas ist es,
jetzt Bilder zu bekommen von möglichst vielen toten palästinensischen Kindern und Zivilisten,
die dann in die Welt gehen und heutzutage, ich meine, wir haben zwar jetzt Wasser
und Strom und alles abgestellt, aber Internet kommt irgendwie trotzdem noch durch.
Keine Ahnung wie, aber irgendwie Daten sickern trotzdem dort raus.
Starlink Antennen und so. Also Satellitennetz gibt es natürlich auch.
Ja und selbst wenn sie dann was
weiß ich, USB Sticks oder Handys durch die Tunnel nach draußen schicken.
Also die Bilder werden von Grausamkeiten, werden da rauskommen.
Das lässt sich heutzutage einfach nicht unterbinden und damit rechnet eben auch Hamas,
sodass sie die Zivilbevölkerung nicht wirklich schützen wollen,
sondern eigentlich so viele tote Zivilisten wie möglich in kurzer Zeit sehen wollen.
Und dazu setzen sie ja generell auch in Kriegsverbrechen menschliche Schutzschilde
ein, wie es so schön heißt.
Also positionieren dann Zivilisten rund um Waffenlager oder lagern Waffen unter
Krankenhäusern oder so. Das ist halt ja, das, was sie tun so.
Und deswegen, ja, wird es halt sehr, sehr schwierig werden bzw.
Das Gefühl, dass so ein Einmarsch jetzt in den Gaza-Streifen.
Der Hamas erst mal voll in die Hände spielt und zu den Entführten und so,
das spielen die jetzt auch noch ganz,
ganz krass und die haben nämlich dann von den Entführten teilweise auch die
Nummern von Freunden und Verwandten aus den Handys rausgeholt und rufen jetzt
gerade wohl direkt auch bei Freunden und Verwandten der Entführten an und kontaktieren
die, um Druck aufzunehmen.
Aufzubauen. Und ja,
schon gesagt, dass Israel ist vielleicht in der Hinsicht eine recht offene Gesellschaft,
eine Demokratie, auch wenn die jetzt auch in Gefahr ist durch den letzten Rechtsruck.
Aber ja, da findet halt schon einfach eine lebhafte Debatte in der Gesellschaft statt, über alles.
Und man liebt auch Untersuchungen. Also es wird zu der Frage,
ist alles schief gegangen und so wird es und also
dieser Konflikt wird auch von den Israelis
selbst ziemlich auseinandergenommen werden und interessanterweise gibt es ja
mittlerweile auch in der israelischen Presse gerade auch sehr viel Kritik trotz
allen Zusammenrückens und sagen Einheit und Einheitsregierung,
jetzt brodelt es trotzdem schon gewaltig, weil das natürlich gerade die israelische
Gesellschaft vor jede Menge Dilemma darstellt.
Es gibt keine gute Lösung.
Und im Moment sieht es auch so aus, als würden sie dann im Moment noch das Spiel
von Hamas mitspielen oder mitspielen müssen, leider die Israelis.
Also ich meine, da werden Sie auch schon mal was von gehört haben,
dass das die Strategie der Hamas ist.
Und alle Auseinandersetzungen auch mit der Hezbollah in diesem Krieg da 2006
und mit Hamas in Gaza auch schon bisher,
es ist halt eigentlich immer darauf hinaus gelaufen, dass irgendwann so eine
Übersättigung der weltweiten Öffentlichkeit mit dem Thema da ist und sozusagen
das politische Kapital dann verbraucht ist,
diese Maßnahmen weiter zu tragen.
Allerdings glaube ich, dass wir es jetzt bei dieser Auseinandersetzung mit einer
anderen Dimension zu tun haben.
Dass jetzt hier nicht nach zwei Wochen irgendwie Ruhe sein wird und sich Israel
dann irgendwie auf irgendeinem Status quo einlassen wird,
sondern sie werden jetzt bestimmte Ziele, die ich nicht genau benennen kann,
die sie wahrscheinlich auch selber so nicht benennen werden,
sondern die nur vage mit von der Hamas Das soll keine Gefahr mehr ausgeben, beschreiben.
Diese Ziele werden sie erreichen wollen und da werden sie sich sicherlich auch
von vielem nicht abhalten lassen.
Droht natürlich die Gefahr eines Flächenbrands im Sinne von eines Kriegseintritts anderer Parteien.
Allerdings habe ich eben, das hast du ja auch vor einiger Zeit schon mal angesprochen,
noch nicht unbedingt so den Eindruck, dass jetzt die anderen Gruppen alle so
begeistert sind, in diesen Terror der Hamas mit einzusteigen.
Während halt dieses schon ritualhaft vorgetragene,
wir unterstützen Palästinenser bei ihrem Freiheitskampf, dass das sozusagen
natürlich gebetsmühlenartig wieder wiederholt werden wird und es gibt natürlich Demonstrationen etc.
Pp. sind glaube ich die Politiker und die Diktatoren oder die Machtpersonen
in den anderen Ländern nicht unbedingt jetzt so scharf darauf,
sich mit Israel anzulegen.
Nicht nur weil sie vernichtend geschlagen werden können, sondern weil es auch
einfach gar nicht mehr so sehr in ihrem Interesse ist.
Wir haben ja gerade gesehen, und das mag ein Auslöser gewesen sein,
dass die Hamas eigentlich verhindern möchte,
dass es zu einer Aussöhnung zwischen Israel oder einer Normalisierung der Beziehungen
zwischen Israel und Saudi-Arabien kommt, wie es ja mit anderen Ländern auch
schon stattgefunden hat.
Und das mag ein Teil der Motivation gewesen sein, weil die Hamas,
wie jede Terrororganisation, lebt nur davon, dass es den Konflikt gibt und dass
es irgendwie Auseinandersetzungen und Streit gibt.
Denn dann wird immer nach radikalen Maßnahmen und nach radikalen Führern verlangt
und diese Leute können halt nichts anderes.
Während eben die anderen sich vielleicht auch an anderen Maßstäben orientieren
und nicht halt immer so an dieser ganzen moralischen Überbau orientieren, sondern einfach sagen,
ist eigentlich billiger und bringt mehr Geld. Und das könnten wir ja auch mal machen.
Wie gesagt, die Frage ist, wie viele, also wie selbstbestimmt können die Menschen
im Gaza-Streifen über ihr Schicksal entscheiden.
Und vor dem Hintergrund, die Hälfte der Bevölkerung im Gaza-Streifen ist jünger als 18 Jahre.
Und viele von denen sind eben auch nie aus dem Gaza-Streifen rausgekommen und
haben noch nie einen Israeli oder einen Juden gesehen.
Und sind halt entsprechend dann auch so junge Leute leicht manipulierbar und erst recht,
dachte dann auch so schön Ryan Macbeth, die Arbeitslosigkeit beträgt 50% im
Gaza-Streifen und jetzt drückst du dann so einem 18-Jährigen einmal,
drückst du halt jetzt eine Waffe in die Hand und gibst ihm eine Uniform und sagst ihm.
Hier, du hast jetzt hier was zu melden, du bist jetzt irgendwie hier bei uns
und kriegst jetzt auch Geld und wenn du irgendwie für die gute Sache dein Leben lässt,
dann versorgen wir deine Verwandten oder wie auch immer weit sie gehen müssen,
aber wahrscheinlich müssen sie gar nicht so weit gehen, sondern die dürften
jetzt wahrscheinlich kein großes Rekrutierungsproblem dort haben,
sondern wahrscheinlich sind eher dann limitiert durch ihre Mittel und ihr Geld
und Organisationsstruktur und so.
Aber ja, also ich sehe da nicht allzu viel wirklich Selbstbestimmungsmöglichkeiten,
sondern da ist halt sehr viel, was von außen kommt.
Und was jetzt die Eskalation angeht, da haben die USA ja sehr schnell dann auch
klar gemacht, zwei Flugzeugträger geschickt und glaube ich deutlich auch signalisiert,
also wenn jetzt irgendjemand vorhat, da irgendwie jetzt noch mit rein zu grätschen, lasst es lieber.
Und ich bin mir auch nicht ganz sicher, oder ich habe auch das Gefühl,
dass die Hamas ein bisschen zu krass war oder ein bisschen zu erfolgreich war.
Und dadurch jetzt auch, und das hat dann Netanjahu gleich auch den Vergleich
zu ISIS gezogen, oder zum IS, wie sich dann zum islamischen Staat.
Das ist es wert, in dem Kontext auch noch mal ganz kurz beleuchtet zu werden,
weil wir haben ja alle irgendwie Krieg gegen Terror und dann war ja dieser komische islamische Staat,
der da so im Irak und in Syrien und auf dann mehrere Millionen Kämpfer und viele
tausende Quadratkilometer an Land besetzt hat und die eben auch absolut,
ja kann man sagen barbarisch unterwegs waren und eben auch alle möglichen Gräueltaten
und Enthauptungen und Kinder und Frauen und von den Jesiden hat man vielleicht noch gehört,
wo sie ja dann jesidische Frauen verschleppt haben.
Jedenfalls war der islamische Staat so schlimm und so krass,
dass er es geschafft hat, wirklich praktisch alle Staaten der Welt gegen sich aufzubringen.
Also niemand stand auf der Seite der IS. Er hatte dann sowohl Iran als auch
Saudi-Arabien gegen sich, Russland, Amerika, den gesamten Welt, also alle.
Es war sozusagen IS gegen die Welt.
Und wurde dann auch erfolgreich dadurch bekämpft und zurückgedrängt.
Und Netanyahu versucht jetzt natürlich Hamas auf eine Stufe mit IS zu stellen
und hat da durchaus auch einen Punkt,
weil die Gräueltaten, die Hamas begangen hat, tatsächlich so von dem,
was der islamische Staat gemacht hat, nicht zu unterscheiden ist.
Der Unterschied ist allerdings jetzt, dass.
Der islamische Staat über Millionen Menschen verfügte und Ölquellen und Geld und am Expandieren war.
Das heißt, tatsächlich auch eine reale militärische Gefahr dargestellt hat,
während in dem Sinne jetzt Hamas militärisch gesehen keine Gefahr für die Existenz Israels ist.
So das kann man glaube ich auch einfach mal feststellen ja mit seinen 30.000 oder 50.000,
Kämpfern und der Ausstattung ist das,
was sie geschafft haben, das Maximum dessen
oder ja was was vorstellbar ist ja unter optimalsten Überraschungsbedingungen
und es war eben also das Maximale zu sie fähig sind ist eben dieser wie so schön
heißt rate also im Prinzip eindringen in feindliches Territorium und sich dann wieder zurückziehen.
Also sie sind nicht in der Lage jetzt dauerhaft irgendwie Teile von Israel zu besetzen oder oder so.
Oder wahrscheinlich werden sie auch noch nicht mal nicht mal zu weiteren Raids
jetzt in der Lage. Also militärisch gesehen ist da nicht nicht viel. Aber.
Umgekehrt, wenn wir jetzt zu dem Punkt kommen, was ist denn realistisch für
Israel jetzt militärisch möglich?
Wie kann das denn jetzt laufen? Irgendwann, okay, kann Israel jetzt einfach
den Gaza-Streifen durchkämmen und sämtlich Hamas-Mitglieder festnehmen?
Ja, das wäre ja so, ich sag mal, die Idealvorstellung.
Also quasi so eine Art Polizei- oder Antiterroreinsatz, wo man dann die Terroristen
verhaftet und verurteilt und ins Gefängnis steckt und die Zivilisten verschont
und die Geiseln befreit.
Das wäre das große Wunschdenken, was man gerne erreichen würde.
Militärisch gesehen, so die Einschätzung, die ich gehört habe,
unter anderem von Ryan Macbeth, ist, wenn Israel dort jetzt hineingeht,
ganz praktisch, mit Bodentruppen, werden sie halt mit Panzern und Panzerkampffahrzeugen
und Infanterie vorrücken und Häuserblock um Häuserblock sichern,
also von, ja, durchsuchenden Leuten entweder festnehmen oder wenn sie Widerstand leisten,
töten, Sprengfallen und Sprengsätze
und so weiter entfernen und wenn sie dann auf Widerstand stoßen,
werden sie dann, ja, was weiß ich, so ein Maschinengewehrnest irgendwo oder
so werden sie dann einen Luftangriff anfordern und das ja.
Was da sie vor sich sehen und so auf diese Art und Weise schaffen sie in der
Größenordnung von 500 Metern am Tag die Frontlinie vorzuschieben und alles zu sichern.
Das ist wohl so in etwa womit man rechnen kann.
Und aber auch das nicht auf der kompletten Front sozusagen, sondern an einzelnen Stellen?
An einzelnen Stellen, genau. Können sie so ungefähr 500 Meterweit vordringen,
vielleicht auf einem halben Kilometer Breite oder so, auch oder einem Kilometer
Breite das Ganze sichern und die Flanken dann auch zu sichern und so.
Und das Ganze wird auch nicht ohne Verluste abgehen,
weil wie du schon richtig sagtest, da sind halt Tunnel und dann vorbereitet
Stellen, wo wahrscheinlich sich Sprengsätze sind oder
aus denen Scharfschützen verdeckt schießen
können und und so weiter und das heißt bei einer Aktion dieser Art rechnet man
mit sechs Prozent Verwundeten oder Getöteten pro Tag also sechs Prozent Casualties,
Verluste wie es so schön heißt und davon vielleicht so ein zwei Prozent ungefähr tatsächlich getötete.
Das heißt, jeder Tag wird auch für Israeler Sisa Formash dann tatsächlich schmerzhaft sein.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie gesagt, dann kommen die Bilder und dann ist die
Frage, wie lange wird die Welt zuschauen und da zu Schätzungen, naja, so 14 Tage.
Wenn dieser Vormarsch läuft, dass dann der öffentliche Druck auf Israel zu stark
werden wird, weil die Bilder einfach zu unerträglich werden.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Erwartungshaltung von Profis, dass das irgendwie so läuft.
Mit anderen Worten, es ist nicht möglich, erstens überhaupt jetzt nur physikalisch
den gesamten Gaza-Streifen zu durchkämmen.
Und dann ist das andere Problem, aber wenn die jetzt auf irgendjemanden stoßen,
der hat ja keinen Hamas-Mitgliedsausweis dabei oder keine Hamas-Uniform unbedingt,
sondern du kannst dann auch nicht irgendwie,
ja, beliebig Leute verhaften oder selbst wenn du halt hingehst und sagst,
okay, wir verhaften erstmal die gesamte männliche wehrfähige Bevölkerung so ungefähr, ja.
Also es geht halt nicht. Kannst du nicht machen, ja.
So, das heißt, das Endgame für Israel an der Stelle, ja, also...
Ist nicht klar definiert.
Ist nicht klar definiert. Also es ist, ja, das Endbild, wie, wie, wie...
Wie soll es gehen? Und da meinte auch Ryan Macbeth so schön.
Und das sind dann so Situationen wie Afghanistan, wo es einem dann so geht wie in Afghanistan,
wenn man nicht weiß, wie eigentlich so das Endbild aussehen soll,
wenn man eine militärische Operation beginnt.
Weil es ist ja auch immer das ganze, okay, eine Sache, quasi eine militärische
Operation zu beginnen, aber irgendwann musst du sie auch beenden.
Und unter welchen Bedingungen bist du dann in der Lage, sie zu beenden?
Und welche Ziele hast du dann eigentlich erreicht?
Und im Moment sieht es so aus, wenn Israel sich nicht irgendwas ganz Schlaues einfallen lässt,
sondern diese Nummer mit dem Einmarsch von Bodentruppen durchzieht,
dass sie eigentlich nichts erreichen werden, nicht wirklich,
oder kein klares Ziel erreichen werden.
Oder das erklärte Ziel ist, irgendwie Hamas komplett zu zerstören und aus dem Gaza zu vertreiben.
Das sehe ich nicht, wie das möglich sein soll.
Du kannst ja nicht mal ohne weiteres unterscheiden, GASA-Mitglieder von Nicht-Mitgliedern.
Also ich meine, wir müssen an der Stelle auch festhalten, dass wir vieles ja auch nicht wissen.
Unter anderem haben wir keine Vorstellung davon, wie groß tatsächlich die Intelligenz
ist, was Israel über Hamas zu wissen glaubt.
Also wir wissen es. Wie genau ist Ihre Kenntnis über die Kommandostrukturen?
Welche Personen und Familien dort eine Rolle spielen? Ein Teil wird davon schon
bekannt sein, weil Sie werden auch Kollaborateure in Gaza gehabt haben in irgendeiner
Form. Also Sie sind ja nicht komplett blind. Sie stehen ja nicht komplett nur vor der Tür.
Sicherlich wissen sie nicht alles, aber sie werden schon eine gewisse Vorstellung
davon haben, wer diese Kommandostruktur ausmacht, wer die Profiteure des Systems
Hamas sind und deren Besitz, machen wir uns nichts vor.
Das mag zwar jetzt so eine Gruppe sein, die religiös erleuchtet ist und so weiter,
aber am Ende ist das halt auch nur so eine machtgetriebene Organisation,
wo Einzelne sich den ganzen Mammon zusammenfegen und versuchen da ein Good Life zu führen.
Ja, aber die eigentliche Hamas Führung sitzt in Dubai, in den Emiraten,
die sitzen irgendwo am Pool mit dem Handy und managen das im Wesentlichen von da aus.
Meinst du?
Ja, ja, ja, das ist so. Das ist so. Also die eigentliche, ja und wahrscheinlich
ist der Großteil der Leute, die im Gaza Streifen sitzen, wahrscheinlich austauschbar.
Ja, aber nicht vollständig.
Also es muss doch schon eine halbwegs ausgebildete, eingeweinte und auch mental
ausreichend radikalisierte und fähige Gruppe von Leuten geben,
die diesen Apparat und auch diesen Unterdrückungsapparat...
Die du nicht einfach nur irgendwie bezahlen kannst, sondern die müssen auch
mental involviert sein. Und das ist natürlich schon das, was in Gaza konkret
die Bedrohung für Israel darstellt.
Dass es irgendwo Leute gibt, die in Dubai am Telefon sitzen,
viel Einfluss und Geld haben und Israel hassen.
Dafür gibt es sicherlich nicht nur in Dubai eine ganze Menge,
sondern around the world.
Nur die Frage ist ja für Israel, wie sieht die konkrete realistische Sicherheitsbedrohung
vor Ort innerhalb des Ranges von Raketen aus und wie können wir das machen?
Das heißt, sie wollen Raketenmaterial, Abschussorte, Fahrzeuge,
Tunnel, diese ganzen Dinge, die wollen sie sichern.
Also das ist einfach eine ganz einfache militärische Antwort an der Stelle.
Inwiefern man jetzt einen Sieg verkünden kann und wann das jetzt so ist,
weil man sich sicher sein kann genug Infrastruktur zerstört zu haben und vielleicht
auch genug Profiteure hops genommen zu haben.
Das weiß ich natürlich auch nicht.
Also ich sehe derzeit nicht, dass selbst Israel mit seinen 500.000 Soldaten,
ich meine die können ja auch nicht alle 500.000,
Großteil davon ist Logistik und so weiter und die müssen auch noch den Rest des Landes bewachen.
Ich sehe nicht, dass Israel tatsächlich in der Lage ist, militärisch zu kämpfen.
Das Ziel zu erreichen. Also was du wahrscheinlich bräuchtest,
ist ein kompletter Overkill.
Ich sag mal zwei oder drei Millionen UN-Truppen, die du da durchschickst in einer Polizeiaktion.
Aber selbst das wahrscheinlich stößt auf Grenzen,
weil wie gesagt, du sagst ja,
wie gut ist die Die Aufklärung, ich meine Hamas ist eine Terrororganisation
mit einer entsprechenden Zellenstruktur,
wo man natürlich allein schon aus Sicherheitsgründen,
die ist halt auch ein ganzes Stück weit Mossad gehärtet,
auch wenn ich sicherlich, ja gebe ich dir recht, ich gehe auch davon aus,
dass die Israelis eine Menge wissen, aber eben auch eine Menge nicht wissen.
Ich sehe es praktisch nicht, wie sie das Ziel,
die vollständige Entfernung von Hamas aus dem Gaza-Streifen militärisch hinkriegen,
außer, ja gut, was sie aber auch nicht können, die können jetzt nicht zwei Millionen
Leute umbringen im Gaza-Streifen.
Sie können auch keine 200.000 Leute umbringen.
Das wird so auch nicht passieren. Und ich habe mir auch genau die internationalen
Reaktionen angeschaut,
wie, was sagt denn jetzt die offizielle Politik, was sagen Regierungschefs dazu
oder in dem Fall der amerikanische Verteidigungsminister.
Und blinken oder generell die Art, damit umzugehen,
So ist natürlich erst mal Israel die, ja nicht uneingeschränkt,
aber die volle Solidarität zu versprechen und Unterstützung und Hilfe.
Und Deutschland schickt ja jetzt sogar zwei Heron-Drohnen, ich weiß nicht,
ob du das mitgekriegt hast, die für die Ausbildung bei der Bundeswehr eingesetzt
werden. Ich glaube, die kommen aus Israel, die Drohnen.
A. Heron klingt auf jeden Fall hebräisch. B.
Ja. Und die Bundeswehr hat aber nur zwei, sodass jetzt gerade keine Bundeswehrsoldaten
mehr an Herondrohnen ausgebildet werden können wahrscheinlich.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, was das jetzt wieder ist. Aber egal.
Also sagen sowohl die ganzen europäischen Länder, Aber auch die USA sagen irgendwie,
ihr habt unsere volle Unterstützung und wir helfen euch und wir stehen auf eurer
Seite und Hamas geht gar nicht.
Aber gleichzeitig dann mit einem wirklich sehr, sehr vorsichtigen Unterton,
um auch Israel darauf aufmerksam zu machen.
Dass sie sich schon an das Völkerrecht zu halten haben, im Großen und Ganzen.
Das kam dann sowohl bei Blinken in seiner Rede zum Ausdruck,
ganz subtil, und jetzt auch unsere Außenministerin Baerbock in ihrem Tweet schrieb dann so,
Das sinngemäß, dass die Israelis natürlich berechtigt sind, im Rahmen des Völkerrechts
alles zu tun gegen Hamas.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt schon klar, ja, Solidarität absolut mit Israel,
aber es ist kein Freibrief jetzt dort im großen Umfang Kriegsverbrechen zu begehen,
weil da das, oder da ist dann wiederum die Befürchtung auch der USA oder von Europa,
dass wenn die Bilder, die von da kommen, zu krass werden, dass das zu Unruhen
in anderen arabischen Ländern führt und dass das dann quasi erst zu dem Flächenbrand
führt, den man eigentlich verhindern möchte.
Das heißt, ja, Ja, wir hauen da jetzt mal so richtig voll drauf,
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, ist keine realistische Option, einfach keine,
die von den USA toleriert werden würde und auch aus guten Gründen.
Oder wie siehst du das?
Also dass Israel in einem Dilemma steckt ist vollkommen klar,
aber ich glaube, dass das für sie keine neue Situation ist.
Also da werden sie halt ihre Abwägungen treffen und ich denke es hängt primär
auch erstmal von der Reaktion der israelischen Bevölkerung ab und die dürfte
relativ klar sein, dass jetzt hier viel Härte gezeigt werden muss.
Der Benchmark ist für, wir haben unsere Ziele erreicht. Das wird glaube ich
nicht nur auf Regierungsseite entschieden, sondern das wird eben auch in der
Bevölkerung sozusagen freigeschaltet werden.
Und dann erst kommt die internationale Gemeinschaft, die natürlich eine Rolle
spielt, aber die jetzt auch auf Israel nicht beliebig viel Druck ausüben kann.
Das kommt ja auch noch mit dazu.
Von daher, keine Ahnung, muss man schauen, das wird jetzt auch noch von der
Reaktion anderer Player abhängen.
Also was ist mit Hezbollah, was ist mit dem Iran, wie verhalten die sich,
wie sehr wird auch die Diskussion nachhaltig dazu führen, dass diese politischen
Prozesse, die man jetzt angestrebt hat, wie zum Beispiel das Abkommen mit Saudi-Arabien,
wie sehr das wirklich in die Bredouille kommt.
Weil auch davon hängt natürlich die Sicherheit Israels ab.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade Meldungen gelesen, dass Saudi-Arabien sich erstmal
zurücknimmt, aber das muss glaube ich erstmal gar nichts heißen.
Das heißt einfach nur, wir ducken uns jetzt hier erstmal weg,
solange wir ja noch alle am Protestieren sind und wenn ihr da fertig seid,
dann können wir ja nochmal drüber reden und so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt vom Tisch ist, aber das ist natürlich schon
politisches Porzellan, was dort zerschlagen werden kann.
Und worüber wir vorhin auch noch nicht so richtig gesprochen haben,
was ja hier auch noch mit reinspielt, ist die Schwäche der israelischen Regierung an sich.
Wir haben ja, da muss man vielleicht mal kurz noch mal aufdröseln.
Peter Jaho, der jetzt schon seit zwölf Jahren an der Regierung ist,
nicht durchgehend, aber halt immer wieder, der ja eigentlich gerade dabei war,
einen Krieg gegen seine eigene Bevölkerung zu führen.
Nicht literally als Kriegshandlung, sondern eben der bedroht durch zahlreiche
Korruptionsprozesse sich auf eine extrem
rechte, schwer zu kontrollierende Regierungskoalition eingelassen hat.
Und dafür die ein oder andere Kröte hat schlucken müssen, weil er letzten Endes
gerne ein Gesetz durchfechten möchte, was kurz gesagt der Politik ermöglicht,
Gerichtsentscheidungen aufzuheben.
Das wird gemeinhin von der israelischen Bevölkerung als Ende der Demokratie
angesehen, nicht ganz zu Unrecht.
Und seit Monaten gibt es Proteste dagegen in Israel.
Und das war sicherlich auch ein Grund, warum die Hamas jeden Eindruck haben
konnte, dass Israel gerade stark geschwächt ist und seine Konzentration auf
den Gaza-Streifen verloren hat. Und das war ja dann offensichtlich auch so.
Es ging ja soweit, dass Reservisten und vor allem auch Reservistenpiloten,
ganz wichtige Gruppe für die Armee, dort quasi in den Reservistenstreik getreten sind.
Also die haben dann sozusagen ihre regelmäßigen, ich weiß nicht genau,
die müssen dann regelmäßig ja immer wieder Dienst leisten für eine bestimmte
Zeit, keine Ahnung wie das jetzt konkret geregelt ist.
Das haben sie halt nicht gemacht und das hat natürlich den Konflikt weiter befördert.
Aber jedem ist jetzt auch irgendwie klar, dass die Regierung halt auch ihre Mitschuld hat.
Weil einfach dadurch, dass man den Siedlern in Westjordanland,
die dort halt weitere Landnahme betreiben wollen und teilweise auch selber palästinensische
Dörfer angegriffen haben und sowas, dass denen nicht Einhalt geboten wurde,
sondern teilweise auch noch gedeckt wurde.
Dass aber trotzdem die Armee sich dann sozusagen auf die daraus resultierenden
Konflikte sich hat konzentrieren müssen und damit die Aufmerksamkeit von Gaza
weggenommen hat, das werden die auf jeden Fall noch ausbaden müssen.
Und auch das wird natürlich eine Rolle spielen. Immerhin konnten sie sich jetzt
nicht einfach so weiter durchwurschteln, sondern es ist jetzt eine Notstandsregierung
gebildet worden unter Beteiligung von Oppositionsparteien.
Ich habe mir das jetzt leider im Detail nicht genau angeschaut.
Das Parteienumfeld von Israel ist auch sehr kompliziert.
Aber das ist sozusagen auch ein vorübergehender Zustand, der den breiten Konsens
der Bevölkerung auch benötigt, um hier weiter voranschreiten zu können.
Also ich habe da keine wirkliche Antwort drauf, was da jetzt passiert.
Ich wollte nur nochmal klar machen, was die Gemengelage ist.
Ja, was tatsächlich wahrscheinlich mit die ganze Situation angeheizt hat,
ist dieser Rechtsruck, der in Israel stattgefunden hat,
der so ein bisschen in der Trump-Ära begonnen hat,
wo Trump auch Israel ermuntert hat, und Jerusalem auch dann als Hauptstadt zu
nehmen und auch das Konsulat, glaube ich, verlegt hat.
Die Botschaft, die amerikanische Botschaft verlegt hat.
Ja.
Und generell dann auch das Ganze mit einer deutlich aggressiveren Politik gegen
die Araber einhergingen.
Auch eben in der Westbank. Man hat mit anderen Worten an vielen Stellen so die
Temperatur hochgedreht für die Palästinenser.
Und ja, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt hatten, Gaza war eigentlich jetzt eingezäunt
und dann hatte man eben auch den Siedlungsbau auch weiter großzügig vergrößert
und umgekehrt viele Kontrollpunkte,
Schikanen und so für die Palästinenser, also man hat jetzt, das war jetzt,
von dieser rechtsextremen Regierung kam jetzt nicht gerade eine Freundschaftsoffensive.
Die Arabischen Palästinenser. Insofern könnte man jetzt auch argumentieren,
dass, okay, wenn man irgendwie die Temperatur hochdreht und einen Deckel oben
auf den Kessel packt, kann es halt tatsächlich auch irgendwann zu einer Explosion kommen.
Das wäre auch durchaus eine Mechanik, mit der sich das ein Stück weit erklären ließe.
Zumindest aber hat diese Art der Politik sicherlich Hamas durchaus ermöglicht
und auch anderen Gruppen einfacher zu rekrutieren.
Also zumindest dieser Einfluss, glaube ich, war auf jeden Fall faktisch da,
wenn man jetzt irgendwie auf die reine Mechanik guckt, wie es dazu gekommen ist.
Und was jetzt noch zukommt, also im Sicherheitsapparat,
so der Minister für Nationale Sicherheit Israels, dem auch die Polizei untersteht,
ist seit Dezember 2022 Itamar Ben-Gvir.
Also das ist ein rechtsextremer Politiker, wie er im Buche steht.
Und den haben sie zum Chef der Sicherheitsbehörden gemacht und der trägt sicher
keine Ahnung wie viel Verantwortung er jetzt auch dafür trägt.
Der Stelle, aber zumindest ja,
verdient seine Rolle auch einfach einen kritischen Blick, denke ich mal.
Als Minister für nationale Sicherheit Israels, ja, trägt man eigentlich eine
gewisse Verantwortung für die nationale Sicherheit, würde ich jetzt mal so annehmen
und da ist jetzt einiges echt schief gegangen.
Aber ja, ich meine, die andere Seite titelt Das sprießt natürlich auch die Verschwörungstheorien
und Onion brachte einen schönen Artikel, angeblich ein Zitat von Netanyahu.
I don't know about you, but the timing of this tragic attack on the Israelis
could not have come at a better time for me.
Also, ich kann tatsächlich konstatieren, dass für Netanyahu politisch gesehen
das Ganze erst mal den Tag gerettet hat.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem nicht, ich glaube der Schaden, der Reputationsschaden
und das, was hinterherkommt, ist einfach zu gewaltig.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendjemand, auch Netanjahu oder
irgendwelche Rechtsextremisten wissentlich in Kauf genommen hätten.
Nein, vor allem, das ist ja auch eine Niederlage in seinem Kernkompetenzbereich,
in seinem sogenannten, also er war ja immer schon so Law and Order mäßig und
dass er das jetzt quasi zu verantworten hat, das wird schon zu seiner Abwahl
oder vielleicht auch zu seinem Rücktritt führen.
Aber eine These von Macbeth, die ich wirklich sehr interessant fand,
war zu der Frage auch noch mal, was ist da schief gelaufen, warum,
also Ägypten soll gewarnt haben und wie gesagt, vorhin das Thema Mossad und
so, wieso wusste keiner was?
Und seine Theorie ist, die Informationen lagen im Prinzip alle vor dem Mossad.
Aber das ganz sah halt viel zu verwegen aus.
Also jetzt auf dem Papier meinte, da sitzt jetzt so ein Analyst und der hat jetzt irgendwie ja,
irgendwie sie werden von See aus angreifen und aus der Luft und irgendwie an
zehn Stellen den Zaun durchbrechen und mit einer Cyberattacke alles lahmlegen und tausende von...
Stell dir vor, dieser Sicherheits... also dieser Mensch,
der dann jetzt dieses Papier weitergeben soll, wo das jetzt drin steht,
muss einfach um seinen Job fürchten, weil jeder sagt, sag mal,
tickst du eigentlich noch ganz sauber, das ist doch hier komplett Hollywood. No way.
Und deswegen, weil seine These ist, die Informationen lagen vor,
vielleicht nicht alle irgendwie zusammengeführt, aber irgendjemand in der Kette
hat gesagt, das ist nicht glaubwürdig, das ist unrealistisch.
Das wird sich Hamas nie trauen und die sind zu so einer komplexen Operation nie im Leben in der Lage.
Das ist irgendwie so, check mal deine Quellen,
so nach dem Motto und dass deswegen es quasi versickert ist und gar nicht erst
möglicherweise nach oben gekommen ist, weil es einfach unrealistisch war.
Naja gut, also das ist auf jeden Fall die Situation.
Es wird jetzt für Israel nicht einfach, aber wir werden auf jeden Fall eine Bodenoffensive sehen.
Während wir hier die Sendung aufnehmen, gibt es auch ein Statement von der israelischen
Armee, dass sie das jetzt sozusagen auch vorhaben.
Also dass sie jetzt sozusagen einen koordinierten Angriff aus der Luft zu Wasser
und zu Lande führen werden, ohne natürlich jetzt hier Details abzugeben,
aber das wird definitiv bald passieren.
Und dann werden wir ja schauen, wie sich die Situation dann darstellt.
So, ja, jetzt steht also dieser Kampf bevor.
Sicherlich, abgesehen davon, wie man das jetzt bewertet, wer woran einen Sieg
oder eine Niederlage festmachen kann, ist klar, dass es hier einen Player gibt.
Beiden Seiten, der jetzt schon verloren hat. Und das ist halt einfach die Bevölkerung.
Das betrifft natürlich die israelische Bevölkerung durch die Terroranschläge.
Das ist natürlich alles nachhaltig.
Wird das die Gesellschaft verstören? Hat sie ja auch schon verstört.
Und viele sind halt ums Leben gekommen. Aber dasselbe findet ja jetzt auch in Gaza statt.
Man hat ja im Prinzip einen Kampf gegen die Hamas, das sind halt 30.000,
50.000 super Radikale, die aber eigentlich die zwei Millionen,
die dort leben, weitgehend als Geiseln halten, kann man fast sagen.
Und die natürlich jetzt einen Großteil des aufkommenden Krieges dann auch ausbaden
muss durch Todszerstörung der Lebensgrundlage, Verletzungen und was den Krieg
halt alles noch nach sich zieht.
Israel hat jetzt eine totale Blockade beschlossen und auch bereits durchgesetzt.
Das heißt kein Gas, kein Strom, kein Wasser,
was nach Gaza geliefert wird und damit ist natürlich die Lebensgrundlage allein
schon zerstört, ganz unabhängig vom ganzen Krieg.
Das heißt, wir werden es jetzt hier auch so oder so mit einer Flüchtlingsbewegung
zu tun haben. Also wer auch immer aus Gaza noch rauskommt, sozusagen.
Und je nachdem, ob Ägypten da die Grenzen auch noch öffnet für einen humanitären Korridor.
Aber viele werden es einfach nicht schaffen. Und das wird natürlich dann auch
entsprechende Auswirkungen haben.
Ja, es gibt wohl jetzt eine Einigung auf einen Korridor für Ausländer.
Also Ausländer dürfen wohl, sollen wohl raus dürfen über Ägypten, aber nur Ausländer.
Weil, wie gesagt, Ägypten, so Muslimbrüderschaft, die wollen keine Hamas,
Ägypten will keine Hamas-Leute reinlassen.
So, das kann man glaube ich festhalten.
Ja, von daher kann man da wirklich wenig Hoffnung haben, was das betrifft.
Und ich verstehe auch viele Leute, die an der Stelle so eine Zerrüttung spüren,
wenn sie sich das ganze Geschehen anschauen.
Also ich kann eigentlich nur hoffen, dass
Israel trotz dieses traumatischen Schocks in der Lage ist und die Führung dort
das notwendige Fingerspitzengefühl walten zu lassen und nicht vollständig in die Falle zu tappen,
die ihnen Hamas gestellt hat.
Israelis sind auch, glaube ich, durchaus zu pragmatischem Handeln in der Lage,
aber ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, wie weit das in so einer extremen Situation überhaupt möglich ist.
Und das könnte es aber am Ende sogar einfach nur schlimmer für Israel und die
Menschen in Gaza machen.
Und das ist meine große Befürchtung.
Ich habe durchaus Hoffnung, weil Israel dann doch auch noch eine offene Gesellschaft
ist und dass die Welt halt dort drauf schaut und dass sich auch alle Beteiligten
ihrer Verantwortung halbwegs bewusst sind.
Eine Lösung finden, die möglichst Opfer vermeidet und irgendwie die Menschen
im Frieden näher bringt.
Diese Hoffnung möchte ich nicht aufgeben.
Im Moment sieht es aber erst mal nicht gut aus.
Aber wir werden sehen, was die nächsten Tage bringen.
So, jetzt haben wir auch schon genug geredet, glaube ich, erstmal hier für den Auftakt zu dem Thema.
Unser Ziel war ja so ein bisschen zu sammeln, mal die Sache zu kontextualisieren
und so. Seht uns nach, wenn wir irgendwelche Details nicht hundertprozentig
korrekt niedergelegt haben.
Wir werden da Fehler gemacht haben. Wir tasten uns da ja auch heran.
Und es ist auch generell sehr schwierig, glaube ich, in dieser Situation,
auch zu diesem Zeitpunkt, hier schon eine Bewertung von allem vornehmen zu können.
Ja, und es gibt noch eine Menge Aspekte, die wir gerne angesprochen hätten,
aber die, wo wir jetzt gemerkt haben, die würden einfach den Umfang dieser Sendung
sprengen und hoffentlich kriegen wir die in kommenden Sendungen unter.
Ja genau. Wir freuen uns trotzdem auf eure Kommentare und Anmerkungen dazu und ja,
hoffen, dass euch das so auch gefällt,
dafür könnt ihr auch gerne mal was in den Kommentaren hinterlassen und wie wir
da weitermachen wollen, ob ihr Fragen habt, Sachen die wir diskutieren wollen,
das nehmen wir gerne auf und dann schauen wir mal wie es weitergeht.
Alright, dann sagen wir erstmal tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut.